- What up squad?
Guess what?
Trash Taste has partnered up
with the folks over at
GamerSupps to bring to you
the very own Trash Taste Waifu cup.
- Ooh!
- Look at this!
These cups are a one-time
limited edition drop
that will never be released again.
- As you can see, we've been constantly
drinking out of these GamerSupps cups
and they've given us our
own special cup this time
which is only available for two weeks.
- Of course you love drinking RGB,
and you can do that with
every single GamerSupps flavor
in your very own Trash Taste gamer cup.
- Look at the girl on
the front. Cute as hell.
- Yeah. I think it's supposed
to be like, female me.
- Is it?
- Yeah.
- Well 'cause,
we had one design each.
- Also, you're doing like the Jojo-
- Yeah, that's why!
- Yeah you are!
You are doing the Jojo pose.
- It's me!
- Oh look!
- As an attractive woman.
- Damn, look at those tits!
- With giant badonkadonks.
- Love what they did there.
- And I'm Jojo posing, of course.
- So if you wanna grab one for yourself,
use our code Trash Taste
and click the link down
in the description below.
- On with the episode!
When I wake up on the
wrong side of the bed
and I'm just like, uh ...
(laughing)
- What's wrong? Why would I wanna do this?
- 'Cause it's a cool vocal thing!
- What, so you can sound
like you're in Dune?
Like ...
(chill music)
- What's up you humid hombres?
Welcome back to another episode
of the Trash Taste podcast.
- I could fucking hear like
your gears turning in your brain
as you were just like, I
gotta think of something.
- Hombres?
- I gotta think of saying ...
- Hombre!
- Hombre?
- Is that the correct pronunciation?
- No, I just love saying it like that.
It's like saying "Jose"
instead of "Ho-se." You know?
(chuckling)
- Jose!
(laughing)
- Spanish language is quaking.
- Josie!
(laughing)
- So the Pitbull album, right?
- Yeah.
- Dale.
- Dale?
- (indistinct)
- Dale, right?
- Yeah, jala-peno.
- Oh god, okay, that one ...
- Jala-peno.
- Okay, that one I actually kinda ...
- Jala-penos.
- But yeah, I am hombre number one
with hombre number two and three,
Connor and Garnt.
- Hey! We're the hombres.
- Hello.
- We're the hombres-
- For today.
- And you've just been clickbaited, baby!
We're not leaving Japan!
- Well, no, you haven't been clickbaited,
because we are leaving Japan!
- [Joey] True.
- Technically. In a sense.
In a sense.
- Technically speaking.
- If you leave Japan and come
back, you still left Japan.
- Yeah.
- This just sounds dramatic.
- So you weren't clickbaited.
You were just tricked.
(laughing)
- No, don't say that Joey!
- You weren't tricked. You
weren't tricked either!
It's true as well.
It's dramatic, we're just being dramatic.
- We may be over-drama ...
No, we just dramatized it.
We didn't over-dramatize it.
- It's not overly dramatized.
- It's like, you know,
when you're at a party,
instead of individually going around
being like, "I'm heading off
now, I'll see you guys later."
It's going, "Guys, I'm leaving!"
And then walking out.
- And I am not returning for
a considerable amount of time!
- Yes, which is basically
what every YouTuber does!
Like, when someone says, "I'm leaving,"
YouTube or something, it's just like,
oh, someone's burnt out and needs a break.
Okay, okay, okay.
I get it, I get it.
You need one more like, YouTuber video,
to like, you know,
gain the clicks before
you go on your holiday.
- Of course. So this is that
YouTube video for Trash Taste.
But like, yeah, we'll
explain why in a second,
but like, can I,
I wanna make a quick announcement.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- For myself, if you would let me.
- I started my own clothing brand.
- Oh, did you actually?
- I'm wearing it right now.
- [Garnt] Oh fuck yeah!
- I was gonna ask, I was
like ... what is this?
- So, yeah, I've been working
on this for like, a year.
- Right.
- Okay, nice!
- In secret.
- Oh nice!
- No one knows about it. Until now.
Like they didn't know about it.
- I'm like, oh, what?
(laughing)
- So yeah, by the time
this episode comes out,
it will be like, pretty
much close to launch.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- So I figured while we're here,
I'll just announce it.
- Building up hype.
- Nice, nice, nice.
- What's the brand called?
- It's called Nonsense.
- Oh okay.
I was gonna ask if it's
called Fuck That Noise.
- It's not called Fuck The Noise.
So this is just one of them.
Actually, Kai, can you go upstairs and get
the other shirt I have?
But yeah, so ...
- This episode is sponsored by Joey!
- This episode is sponsored by me!
(laughing)
- Are we getting a cut?
- You get mates rates.
- Oh okay, all right, okay okay.
Free (indistinct).
- Yeah, free (indistinct).
- I got it, I got it.
- Yeah, but,
you know, I figured,
this would be the perfect
opportunity to like,
announce it, since you
guys don't know about it.
Yeah, I have another shirt here.
- What made you decide to start
working on a clothing brand?
- I like drip!
- Yeah!
- You know? And it's like,
there's a lot of drip I like
and there's a lot of drip I like wearing,
but like, you know,
what better way to flaunt out my drip
than to just make my own drip.
- [Garnt] Just make ...
- Yeah, so this is ...
- Joey's literally went,
"I'll do it myself!"
- I'll do it myself!
So this is the long tee.
- [Garnt] Right. That looks sick.
- [Connor] Ooh, that looks nice!
- Back design's like this.
- Ooh!
- [Garnt] That looks nice!
- Yeah.
You can check that out.
But yeah!
- Damn.
What a business mogul, dude.
- [Joey] Business mogul. Yeah.
- Very nice. Ooh! Very thin!
- Guys, look at this entrepreneur!
- I am now, I can call myself
an entrepreneur, finally!
- Business starter.
You gonna put it in
your Twitter bio though?
- Yeah yeah. Yeah of course, I have to.
- Startup.
- Don't do that.
Don't do that.
- Nonsense founder.
I have to do that!
- Nonsense founder and CEO!
- But yeah, so I've been
working on this brand thing
for like a year now.
- Sorry.
- Great pitch.
- That was ...
(laughing)
I did not mean for that to
be that loud. I'm so sorry.
- [Joey] But yeah, I've been
working on this for like
a year now.
And you know like, I've
always been known to like,
you know, wear good clothes,
and like, I like you know, fashion.
- [Connor] I'm privileged.
- [Joey] I'm privileged.
I'm privileged to wear good clothes.
But you know, I've always been like,
interested in like clothing,
like fashion and
streetwear, stuff like that,
so I was like ...
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- There's so much good
streetwear out there.
- [Connor] Mhmm.
- But like, nothing that was like,
really like speaking to
me, personally, right?
It's like, there's a lot
of good brands and whatnot.
But it's like, so I was just like,
I'll fuckin' do it myself!
I'll make it ...
- Was it a pain in the ass?
- Yeah! Absolutely it
was a pain in the ass!
- I haven't done it, so I don't know.
- Yeah, so like,
yeah so it's like a full
on proper brand or anything
and like, the one thing
I was always scared of,
right, is like,
whenever YouTubers release clothes,
it's usually under the
merch umbrella, right?
- [Connor] Yeah yeah yeah.
- But like, I didn't
want this to be merch.
'Cause it's like, 'cause you know,
these designs, and like,
all the designs we're gonna be releasing
have nothing to do with me
or like the likeness of
me or anything like that.
I want it to just be like,
something separate to me.
- Right.
- That like, in the case that like,
the anime man or whatever
just fucking implodes in on itself, right,
in a couple years time,
that this can still be around.
- Right.
- So it's like, I'm
already not watching anime.
- Exactly! It's already on
the dire straits, right?
So I was like ...
- I'm gonna plan a backup.
- Exactly.
It's already on the dire
straits so I'm like,
you know what?
Like, I'll try something new.
I'll try something, like, challenging.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So yeah.
So by the time this episode is out, like,
all the social media stuff
is probably ready to go.
- We literally didn't know
anything about this, by the way.
- We didn't know anything.
- This is, you do not
understand how hard it was
to keep it a secret from these guys.
- I'm like, Joey's kept
a secret from us boys?
What's going on?
- Like literally I started this
before we moved to this office.
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, like at the old office.
- What?
- Wow.
- So it's been like, over a year.
- Fucking hell!
- That I've been working on this.
So yeah, I'm very passionate about this,
and I want it to do well,
and I hope you guys like it.
- I have so many questions!
I don't know where to start.
- It's all, everything is
designed by me as well.
Like, all sketched by me and everything.
I obviously got designers and everything
to like, clean it up and everything,
but like, all the designs are done by me.
And yeah, I hope people like it,
so check out Nonsense.
We're gonna be doing this thing
where we release a new design every month.
- [Garnt] Okay, okay.
- One new design a month.
'Cause I thought like,
originally I was like,
should I do like the usual
thing where it's like,
oh, I drop, you know,
like a collection,
like a summer collection
or a winter collection.
But I was like, nah,
I'm selling it to people on the internet
and the people on the internet
have the fucking attention
span of a goldfish,
so I'm like, let's just like,
keep bringing stuff out, right?
- Keep the drip dripping.
- Exactly! Keep that
tap just slightly open
so that the water's just
constantly dripping, you know?
Rather than keeping it closed
and then suddenly being like,
"Here you go!"
So yeah, that's the plans for it.
Obviously I'm not like, you know,
fucking quitting anything else.
This is just like another thing
I'm doing on the side, so.
Hey, if you like it,
then check it out, I guess.
And then hopefully
preorders will start soon.
- Was there anything that
was surprisingly difficult
while making your own clothing brand?
That caught you off guard?
- Yeah, like, well for one,
like, you know,
everything's designed by me, but like,
I can't do like graphic design.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
- Or you know like, I can't do like,
logo design and stuff like that, right?
So like, even just coming up with like,
you know, just like the
font and stuff like that
for Nonsense, and like,
I don't know if the logo is anywhere.
But like, yeah, like you know,
just something like that, right?
Like even just coming up with like,
that font, took me like two months.
- Well that's why graphic
designers are like, a job, right?
(laughing)
- I basically just described
what a graphic designer is.
- You're like, damn, this shit hard!
There already a job?
There already a job for this?
- Yeah! Right, because like, you know,
I'm not used to that with
like video creating, right?
It's like, usually it's like,
nine times out of 10,
I think of an idea,
and then I try and make it work
and then whatever I have, you know,
I have to work with, right?
Especially with the
kind of content I make.
So it's like, you know,
even if it's not like, perfect perfect,
I have to get something out there, right?
Otherwise I won't, you know,
I'll have the fuckin' upload schedule of,
you know, 2015 Garnt, essentially.
- [Garnt] Yeah yeah, exactly.
- So it's like, but like,
with this, I have to like,
really be careful with it.
Because I don't wanna
get a design out there
and it just looks like shit.
- Yeah.
- You know? Because it's like,
my brand is on the line, essentially.
- How many fonts did
you have to go through?
- Uh, like ...
Well I mean, for one,
like the actual, the
official font for the brand
is completely custom.
So I had to get like a typographer.
Not a graphic designer, a typographer,
I had to find a typographer,
to be like, and like a font specialist,
to be like, "Here's the brand.
Here's what the brand is about.
Here's the kind of designs I want.
Can you come up with just
like, a shitload of fonts?"
And we literally went
through about 100 fonts
and just decided, that's the one we want.
- Because the thing about fonts is that
it's something that, like,
most people don't really
appreciate or think about.
Until you have to choose one.
Like I remember like,
just having to choose one
just to use for my like,
my YouTube videos, or just like-
- [Joey] Yeah, right?
- A logo or something, and I'm just like,
where the fuck do I even start?
And then you go through like
the Photoshop like, font,
and you like realize ...
- Just Calibri, innit?
(laughing)
- Just Light Arial.
- Yeah yeah.
And then you talk to graph-
- Sans serif?
- Yeah. And then you
talk to graphic designers
and they're just like, they're
just like built different.
They see a font and they
can like, name the font.
- Yeah. They can name the font,
they can name like, the
exact kerning between like,
each of the fonts.
- Yeah, I know right!
- They're like, "That's like
an eight kerning right there."
It's like, what the fuck is all this?
- I don't even know what that means.
- Kerning is like the
space between letters.
- Oh, okay okay.
- So like, I got like a,
you know, working with like
a typographer and everything,
like I gained like a whole
new appreciation for like,
graphic design and
typography, 'cause like,
that shit's hard as fuck!
And I can see why!
You know like, in the case of
like this for example, like,
just changing the spacing,
the kerning between each of the letters,
makes like a completely different design.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you wouldn't
think otherwise, though,
when you make like a
YouTube thumbnail, right?
Yeah, just fucking put the font there
and you're good!
- Right.
- Right, kinda thing.
So it's like, it made me appreciate like,
subtle design.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- If anything.
And like, you know,
because I'm kinda going with like,
kind of a combination between like
streetwear but also loungewear.
- [Garnt] Right.
- So like, you can wear this like,
outside of course, and
you know, it'd be great.
But you can also,
it's comfortable enough
where you can wear it inside.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- As well, so for you weebs out there
that don't go outside,
you can still wear it!
- This is like the longest
Trash Taste ad we've ever done.
(laughing)
- This is an ad that's
not an ad that is an ad.
It's not an ad.
- Yeah, I'm sponsoring myself right now.
- Yeah no, because like,
you know, talking about like,
fonts and having to
choose fonts and just like
being thrown into a world that you just
don't understand sometimes,
that you never knew that, you know,
there was this much thought into it.
Like I remember like recently,
this is like going off on a tangent,
but I remember recently,
I've just got like,
had like a binge.
Not really a binge, but just like,
had my recommended taken over by these
really weird keyboard ASMR videos?
(laughing)
I don't know, I don't know if you guys
know what I'm talking about.
- I think I've seen a
couple of them, yeah.
- I know what you're talking about.
- Because how I basically discovered it
was just this random
keyboard video, right?
And I was just like, why
is there a keyboard video
of just someone typing on my timeline?
So I click on it, just,
because I think the video title was
"Just listen to the
sound of this keyboard,"
or something like that, right?
- [Joey] Right. Yeah, right.
- And it was just like him, like,
or like, him or her,
like just pressing the keys, right?
And just, and the title was,
"Just listen to the space bar," right?
And it's pressing the keys, right?
And then you go to the space bar.
And it just sounded like a space bar.
I was like, "It's just a space bar!"
And then I go to the comments section
to be like, "What's going on?"
And all of the comments were just like,
"I was having a nice time
until you pressed the space bar.
And then I vomited."
And it was just like,
the vomit emotes or something like that,
and I was just like,
I've never been put into a world
that I just did not understand.
- Well, I mean like,
I kinda felt that when,
I think it was Connor, right?
Who got like, I think one
of your fans made like
a custom keyboard for Connor, right?
But then they also, you know,
with the custom keyboard,
which looked sick as fuck,
there was also this like,
other smaller keyboard,
where you could test out ...
- Oh, that was Garnt's.
- Oh, that was me.
- Oh, that was Garnt? Okay.
Where it was like a smaller keyboard
where you could test out all
the different types of keys
and like hammers, and I was just like,
what's the difference?
They are, like, I touched all
of them and I was like ...
Half of these sound the fucking same.
- I think they, as
someone who's like using
one of the expensive keyboards,
'cause, only 'cause it was given to me.
I would never have gone out
my way and paid that much.
To me it was all the same.
Now I get it 'cause I use it.
Before I didn't understand
what the difference was.
But I really like the smoothness,
and like the subtle clicks.
- Yeah, now that I've watched ...
- It's a very slight click,
but it's really nice.
- Yeah, now that I'm like,
like 20 keyboard videos down,
I kinda get it.
There's like a nice ... there's like ...
It's like the thonk sound, right?
It's the thonk sound where it's ...
- Do you though? Or have you just been
conditioned to understand it?
- Maybe I've just been conditioned!
I feel like ...
- Listen, I'm one of you.
Cherry MX Brown Switches can
suck my dick, there you go.
Welcome keyboard enthusiasts.
- Yeah, I'm like ...
- The cherry switches,
I can actually tell,
they fucking suck now.
I used to have it.
- Was it, wait, like why? Why?
- It sounds like a car crashing
every time you fucking press it in.
It's so goddamn loud and clicky.
- Oh, you mean like the clicky one?
- Super super clicky one.
- Okay, fuck those ones.
Fuck, they, like I had one,
in my old office in the UK,
and since I went back to
the UK, I like, I had it.
- It's probably the
Cherry Brown MX switches.
They're like the cheapest ...
- I think it's like the
Cherry Blue MX switches. Yeah.
- Oh okay okay.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
The Gatreon ones?
The Gatreon is like,
Gatreon's where it's at, man.
- I've got the Gatreon Black Ink ones.
- Oh, that's a good one.
That's a good one.
- And like, it's like,
oh it's fucking good.
It's fucking good, dude.
- Yeah, I really like the Gatreon, like,
milk yellow, I believe?
It's literally called something milk,
because it like, it just has this like,
nice little thonk to it,
and it's nice, it's like ASMR, right?
So just, it's so smooth,
and it's so, it's milky!
And it's like milky!
- It just sounds like (indistinct).
(laughing)
- The guy ...
- What the fuck are you talking about?
- He told me like what lube he used.
And I was like ...
I don't need to know
what you jacked off with,
but I mean I appreciate it.
- Yeah, so to explain,
like I'm also getting
a custom keyboard made
because a fan messaged me.
But I like ...
- Dude, I mean like,
I did pay for this thing.
- Yeah, so he was like,
"Oh, do you wanna get a
keyboard made for you?"
And it's in the process of being made.
And I was just like, "Yeah, sure!"
Thinking that he was just going, you know,
he was just going to send
something that he recommended.
And he was like, "No, we're
gonna do the entire process."
- [Joey] Right.
- Like what kinda keyboard do you want?
Do you want like a
100%? Do you want a 75%?
Do you want like a 50%?
And I was just like,
"What? You are saying numbers right now.
It's a keyboard. What
are you talking about?"
- I'll have a full 100% keyboard.
I want a keyboard, and
I want every part there.
- Yeah, why would I only
need 75% of the keyboard?
Gimme the whole thing!
- I don't like the number pad
and all that shit on the side.
I don't.
- I used to not care,
but now that I have a keyboard
that doesn't have a number pad,
I understand why it's
unnecessary to have it.
'Cause I realized until it was gone,
I never fucking used it.
- I know some people
who like, go ham on it,
and like, good for you.
Yeah, good for you.
But I'm out here, I'm totally
fine with the top thing.
Also, I just wanna save room!
- I use the number pad.
- Okay.
- Yeah. Mostly because when you ...
- All right Boomer.
- Huh?
- Just ... mostly, it's useful,
because it's, all the numbers
are just close together!
- No, I agree.
I recognize it's the superior
way to handle numbers.
- It is. It is.
- But I just (indistinct).
- With the amount of like,
two factor authentication I have,
you know what I mean?
Like, I'm constantly using it!
- It's not that long!
- It is! It is! It is.
- This ... there you go.
- Although, I definitely
had a moment where like,
you know, I was like,
you know, I should probably
start using the number pad
on my old keyboard, because it's there.
But then I had a moment
where I was just like,
"Damn, it's so hard to
use with my left hand."
(laughing)
And I was just like
doing this and I'm like,
"Oh, maybe I should just
take my hand off the mouse
and just do this."
- Oh, I thought you were like ...
- I was like, oh, why is
it not on the left side?
It'd be so much easier!
But then I was like, oh,
I could just let go of the mouse,
and perhaps just do this.
- I thought you were implying like
your right hand was like,
on your dick or something.
- [Joey] Oh, like jacking off?
- You're like jacking off and you're like,
(indistinct) my credit card details.
(indistinct)
- When I'm like, jacking
off while like, playing Run.
Like just ...
- I mean, if you're like an
accountant or something, right?
You gotta be pressing numbers all day,
then it obviously makes sense.
- True, true!
- But like, for normal guys ...
- Like, I should be used
to that layout as well
because it's like, you know,
every calculator is that layout, right?
So it's like, why is it
so hard for me to use
when it's on a keyboard?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Even though on a calculator it's like,
basically second nature.
- Yeah, like, I mean,
the reason I like the number pad
is because buying a lot of things online
you gotta enter your
credit card number a lot.
Log into your bank account details.
- How much shit are you buying?
- Yeah!
- It is like, actually
beneficial to have that
real estate taken up.
- Um, like, I don't know,
like, I just have enough ...
I feel like I use it a lot,
because sometimes I need to
log into my bank, and you know,
when you're entering purely just numbers
and it's not like a password,
that's when the number pad is useful.
And like, when you're like,
entering the numbers on a line-
- Marginally, though.
Marginally useful.
I feel like ...
- Mr. Optimization!
I thought you'd be one of me, man!
(laughing)
I thought you'd be one of me!
- Listen, you're trying to
optimize two things at once.
How fast can you type stuff in,
but also the space in your desk, you know?
- [Joey] Right, right.
- I got a lot of like, shit on my desk,
'cause you know, 'cause I got like,
god knows how many,
I got like two audio interfaces.
I got a bunch of other cables.
- I will admit, the aesthetic looks better
without the number pad.
But it's, the aesthetic
looks better, but ...
- Also, travels easier.
You know, tryna put a number,
you can put like a, what are they called?
Are they 75%? Half keyboards?
- Yeah, 75%, yeah.
- 75% keyboard, you can
put that in a backpack.
You can't put a full one in your bag.
That's too big.
Why would you ...
Sometimes you're going somewhere,
I mean you're going to a
LAN event or something.
Not that I do anymore, but.
- When was the last time
you went to a LAN event?
- University.
- Yeah!
I think it was like high school for me.
- But also like, you know,
what if you don't like the
keyboard on your laptop.
I get it, 'cause sometimes
the laptop keyboards suck,
and then you wanna bring one with you
if you're gonna be like,
having your remote setup.
- [Joey] Right.
- Packing like a full size
keyboard in a backpack
is a pain in the ass.
- I've never been that desperate.
I've never been like,
every time I've touched the
laptop keyboard ...
- You don't realize how good having like,
things smaller and
taking up less space is.
- Yeah but like, it's not,
like my laptop keyboard isn't
so fucking detrimental to me
where I'm like, "I gotta
pack another keyboard!"
You know? Like ...
- It's about the ergonomics!
- You are saying that you'd
rather pack a keyboard
without a number pad than
just use the laptop keyboard?
That makes less sense!
- No it doesn't!
- That is the opposite of optimization!
- You're taking up more space now!
You're taking up more space!
- If I'm having like
a remote setup, right?
I'm going to a place,
I'm gonna be streaming,
I'm gonna be playing games.
I don't wanna play games
on the laptop keyboard.
- Just bring a controller!
- Can bring a controller,
but some games don't use controllers!
- Well then don't play those games!
- Okay, well, but I wanna
play these games, Joe!
You're just being pedantic
now for no reason!
- Just play a game that
you can use the controller!
- I know for a fact I'm not alone.
I've seen people do this so many times.
People don't wanna use the
fucking keyboard on the laptop
for like eight hours.
- I'm sure you're not alone,
but it's (indistinct).
- There's so many people who do this!
This is not weird!
- I've never gotten to
the point where, okay,
I have a remote setup, right?
A remote setup is not like
your permanent setup, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But if I really really
really need a keyboard,
I'd just buy like a fucking
five dollar keyboard
or something like that, you know?
Like, it's ...
- No, 'cause then you may
as well use the laptop one,
you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, no, like,
if I really really
wanted like a remote ...
Like a remote setup, but like ...
- It's just about the
ergonomics, you know?
Like using a laptop keyboard for hours,
like actually fucking hurts your wrists.
- Using a keyboard for
hours hurts my wrists.
That's why I try and use a
controller for every game!
- Like a nice keyboard,
you know, good ergonomics,
doesn't hurt your wrists.
- [Man] You bring the rest as well.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
You got the rest too?
Laptops don't have rests!
You know, my laptop, it's amazing, right?
But I have to like,
it's just, there's no support or anything,
I'm just putting my hand ...
- I'll just bring the fucking rest then!
- I just feel like ...
- I mean you gotta put it down
on like the fucking trackpad and shit.
It's kind of in the way,
it's kind of annoying.
Yeah, it just doesn't
work! It doesn't work.
- I just feel like the entire point ...
- Thank god someone in the
office understands this point.
- I just think like,
the whole point of a
laptop is to be portable.
- No, it is!
- Like, and ...
- But what's?
- At that point you might as well just
bring a monitor as well!
- But if the keyboard fits
in the bag, it's portable!
You know what I mean?
Like, you can't bring a (indistinct).
The reason why a laptop's portable
is 'cause it's not a giant fucking case,
not 'cause the keyboard is like, on it.
That's like, one of the reasons.
If I'm whipping it out in a cafe,
yeah, I'm gonna use the laptop keyboard.
I'm replying to emails,
it's not a big deal.
If I'm streaming or gaming,
I want a fucking keyboard.
- But in, how are you like,
if you're at the point where you're
bringing a portable setup, right?
Of like, in which,
tell me this hypothetical situation
where you need to set up
an entire stream setup.
'Cause I'll tell you, it's
not just a fucking laptop
you need to bring.
If you're bringing your
entire fucking stream setup,
how much are you bringing?
Like, what are you bringing?
- Well, when I went to the UK last time
I brought it with me.
You know? You just bring,
'cause if I wanna film some anyway,
I'd bring a camera, anyway.
The camera has two uses.
I can film other stuff.
- Do you bring lights?
- No, I don't bring lights.
You don't need lights.
You know, you can figure out lighting.
It's not a big issue.
It's just having a good
camera, a good mic.
And then if you wanna play games or shit,
you bring a keyboard and a mouse!
You're not gonna fucking
use the trackpad, right?
- No, you're not gonna use the trackpad.
- [Joey] You're not gonna
use the trackpad, but ...
- A trackpad is like, totally
different than a mouse, right?
- Right right, but I mean,
if you have a 75% keyboard,
it's not that big.
- But then like, another thing is like,
are you still gaming on the laptop,
or do you have like a monitor
that you're using as well?
- On the laptop's fine.
The screen I have on my
laptop's pretty good.
- Well that's not very ergonomic, is it?
- Of course it is!
- 'Cause you're fucking going like this!
- No dude! My desk's over there,
my other keyboard's here,
this one's there, it's further away.
'Cause just, I have more room now
'cause the keyboard's
not attached to the thing
so I can place the
screen where I want it to
so it is ergonomic.
- Is it me or does this
just sound very pretentious?
- No, this is not!
This is, if I wanna like,
do a fucking setup!
- If you wanna go portability,
why not go for a 50% keyboard then?
Or?
- A 50%?
- [Joey] Or a 25.
- Or 30%.
- I didn't even know
what 50%, what is a 50%?
How can you remove less?
- There is ... you would be surprised!
You would be surprised, okay?
- What are we removing?
- [Man] Smaller keys.
- Smaller keys.
- Well no, I won't be able to press it!
I already have fat fingers, dude.
I need to like ...
- Why don't you just invent
a keyboard which is just
the space bar and the arrow keys?
- I don't, who uses the arrow keys?
- Yeah.
- Well, if you're playing
games on a keyboard ...
- WASD, dude!
- Okay, or WASD.
- I want all the letters!
(laughing)
I gotta fucking type!
- Yeah, use the fucking laptop typing!
- [Man] So the thing with 50% boards,
you don't have like the numbers on top.
- Right right.
- Yeah yeah.
- I think gaming you need the numbers.
- [Man] Yeah, you need the numbers!
- Like, it is really not that hard
to bring a 75% keyboard in
your bag or in your suitcase.
- It's also not hard to just
bring a fucking controller.
- It's like half of a pizza box!
You know what I mean?
It's like not even, it's tiny!
It doesn't take up room!
And your clothes are the padding!
This isn't hard! Why is
this so crazy to you?
It's like I'm bringing a fucking like,
pet dog in my bag.
Why is this so unbelievable?
- It just sounds-
- Because it's just like, at that point,
at that point where you are bringing ...
- No!
- No, at that point where you're
bringing a streaming setup,
a number pad is not that
much more surface area.
Okay?
- Yeah, but what I'm saying is like,
that's just unnecessary.
Like in general.
Like in any keyboard setup.
- Just put the fucking
keyboard in your checkin!
- Technically if you get a 50% keyboard,
you're removing unnecessary
keys, right? You know?
That's the entire ...
- No it's not!
75% is like the perfect key experience!
- It's called a preference, Connor!
It's called a preference, okay?
- Okay look, I would argue, right?
The reason why 75% is no
different from the 100%
is 'cause you don't lose anything, right?
You just have numbers twice.
I don't need numbers twice.
I just need numbers once!
This is not, why is this,
like you're saying like,
removing the second number pad
is not equal to being like,
"Get rid of half of the alphabet!"
This is not the fucking same at all!
I can't believe this is
an argument you're making!
- I don't know, man.
- [Man] Imagine in a hotel
you're stuck for a week.
- Yeah yeah!
- [Man] You want the TV screen
to be your second monitor.
You leave your laptop there,
and you can sit at your
bed with your wireless 75%.
- Yeah! Every hotel,
every Airbnb has a TV!
- I do not pack a keyboard wherever I go.
- That's fine! But why
are you clowning on me?
This is not like a clown thing to do!
This is a normal thing!
- It just sounds incredibly
pretentious and tedious to me.
- How is it pretentious? What?
'Cause I wanna bring a keyboard?
- Let me just get my 75% keyboard out.
- No no no, because
everyone works differently!
- [Joey] Yeah, I know.
- Like I can't go to a Starbucks and work.
Like that's not, I'd be like, why?
It's so pretentious, Garnt,
if you go to a Starbucks to
type, you know what I mean?
Like, just work from home.
- [Joey] Specifically a Starbucks.
- Specifically!
- Like, I don't see how
this is pretentious!
I'm losing my mind over this argument.
- No no, it's the way that
you're framing it as like,
"This is the superior way to type.
This is the only keyboard that works.
Number pads, irrelevant. Unnecessary."
- Yeah, they are unnecessary!
- Number pads fell off.
- All I'm saying is, you
have your preference,
I like using a number pad
because I use it enough functionally
for me to be able to justify that
it is a convenience for me!
All right? I like number pads!
- Right, but how did this
get to me being clowned on
for bringing keyboards with a laptop?
How did this get ...
- It's Trash Taste, baby!
(laughing)
- That's not the reason you
were clowning on me, Garnt!
The reason you were tryna clown on me
is 'cause I brought a keyboard places.
- 'Cause it's funny, that's why!
- It's a lot, okay?
It's a lot.
I'm just like, there is ...
I understand it's a preference, you know?
I understand it is a preference
that you want to bring your keyboard.
- Have you never thought like,
when you were like, trying to play games,
aren't you like, "Why are my hands
so fucking close to the screen?"
- No.
Because here's the thing, like,
I don't really ... I'm not a gamer.
- Yeah! You have to
understand, we're not gamers.
We're not gamers like you!
- Right, right!
So why don't you just say
that in the first place
instead of pretending like you were?
- I never pretended like I was!
- 'Cause ...
- I told you what I'm
using the keyboard for
and then you're like, "No,
that doesn't make sense."
- Well you're streaming, right?
I also have a portable streaming setup,
but I just don't need a keyboard for it.
- I just, yeah,
I don't think to myself, "I
can't game without this."
- I am a (indistinct)
in League of Legends.
I have a 1% keyboard.
It's the R key, okay?
That's, like you know, like ...
- I just, like if I need to
game while I'm out and about,
I just bring a fucking controller
and just play games that use a controller.
- Yeah but like, what if someone's like,
oh, do you wanna,
you've arranged a game with someone.
The game doesn't have a controller.
- Then I'll use the keyboard.
I'm not gonna fuckin'
have a hissy fit over it
and be like, "Where's my 75%?"
- I wouldn't have a hissy fit!
'Cause I would have
brought it fucking with me!
So there wouldn't have been a hissy fit.
- Yeah, but what if you didn't?
- I always bring it with me!
It's not happening-
- That's just a waste of space!
- It's not a waste of space!
It's fit, it's small!
How is a keyboard a waste of space?
What?
- I don't know, I've ...
- Always fucking arguing.
I just feel like you guys
are just being pedantic.
- Yeah, 'cause it's funny.
- I mean I feel like the argument is,
are you a gamer or are
you not a gamer, you know?
- You are 100% gamer, we're only ...
- Even if I was doing work, you know?
I wanna write a lot of emails and stuff,
to the point of like,
if I'm doing a lot of work, you know,
I'm typing for a few hours,
like yeah, I'm just gonna bring my own.
'Cause like, for me it's like,
I will be so much less efficient
using the laptop one,
'cause I just wanna be comfortable.
- No.
I mean, I'm ... okay.
That is just purely just
you looking for any like, I don't know.
Like ...
- No!
- Because I'm the scriptor here.
I actually write more than you, Connor!
I actually write more than you!
- That's the same like, because,
well you work one way, everyone
must work the same way,
and you've, you like ...
Like, so if someone writes a lot,
they're the ones that we should ask like,
"Okay, tell me about keyboard ergonomics,
and how well ..."
Like, no! That's not how it fucking works!
- Are you saying that you
can't write as efficiently
if you don't have the right
keyboard and everything?
How did you function before like,
the 75% keyboards got popularized?
You know?
Because it was ...
- I'm not doing wingdings!
We're not writing with a
fucking number pad, Garnt!
This has nothing to do with the 75% now!
What are you talking about?
Now we're talking about the
difference between laptop
and keyboard!
- Yeah, I am!
I'm just like, if ...
- Well, so you know your laptop
doesn't have a number pad, right?
- Yeah, I know!
(laughing)
- Like ...
- I'm not saying that it
doesn't have like a number pad.
- That's why he brings
a portable number pad.
(laughing)
- I just bring like a portable number pad!
- No you don't!
- No no no, I don't, I don't.
- He brings a 5% keyboard
that's just the number pad.
- Listen. How you work is
like, totally up to you, right?
If you are a person who
gets really agitated
by a certain way,
and that's just like, that bugs you.
I think that's just, that's up to you.
Could you just knuckle down sometimes
and get on with it? Yeah, you can!
But I mean, at the end of the day it's,
if you're doing something creative
and it's something that
you're your own boss with,
you're probably gonna
work as much as you want.
- Yeah.
- And sometimes, comfort
is a factor in that.
And for me, that's what I need.
- Yeah, but you're gaming.
- Yeah but, if I am
working though, as well!
It's the same thing!
I just don't wanna use it.
- Right right right.
Anyway.
- Anyway!
- I don't even know how we got onto this!
- I don't even know, man!
I don't even know.
- That was the most long-winded,
dumbass argument we've ever
had on Trash Taste, like.
- I just felt like I
explained a very valid point
and then I got jumped on it.
- I don't know.
I don't know what you
were explaining, exactly.
I don't even know.
- I don't even know who you are!
- That it is totally a reasonable behavior
to not wanna use the laptop thing.
- Okay okay.
Because like, maybe it's
because I don't have a
custom keyboard yet, but like,
I don't fully understand-
- I don't take my main keyboard.
I take some like, $50 one that's ...
- I take my side bitch keyboard.
- I just need one that's further away
and that I can set up to be more like ...
- Wait, so you don't even take your good
optimized custom keyboard?
- Not like the super expensive one, no.
I just take like one that I can ...
- So you have several keyboards?
- Yeah! Well I learnt my lesson.
'Cause my keyboard broke one time,
I couldn't do any work or
couldn't stream or anything.
And I, you know, I was fucked.
I was like, well this seems dumb.
So now I just bought, I
have a spare keyboard.
- Yeah, because like ...
- It's a good idea if your entire job
revolves around doing like,
being able to use this one device.
- Yeah.
- You should probably
have backups of everything
that could possibly break.
- That's fair enough, but
I don't think I've ever
broken a keyboard before.
- Keyboards break!
- I didn't break it. They break sometimes.
- All the time, right?
- You know, whether you've
had a key that was acting up
that was pissing you off,
or maybe the, yeah yeah,
it happens all the time.
Keyboards are fucking frail things.
- Yeah, 'cause to me like ...
- Mouses break all the time.
I got like three backup mouses.
- Yeah. 'Cause like,
maybe like this comes down
to the conversation of like,
me in tech, like,
even though I'm an engineer,
I don't like, I just
need a job to be done.
You know what I mean?
I don't really care about aesthetics
or like, stuff too much.
I just like ...
- It's not aesthetics.
I don't care about that.
- You don't? Well.
- It's just about, it's about like,
preference of like, how I like it to work.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Yeah, 'cause like,
for example like headphones, for example.
I literally don't like ...
My preference with headphones
is to buy like the cheapest headphones
I can possibly, right?
- Oh, I'm the opposite with headphones.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
'Cause I know people are like,
really really really anal ...
- When you're talking about headphones
you're talking about in-ear, right?
- In-ear.
- You don't use headphones, right?
- I don't use headphones.
- Like clam shell headphones, you mean?
- Those are headphones, right?
They're earphones.
- Oh sorry, yeah! Earphones!
- Earphones, yeah.
- I only use earphones for like running.
- Yeah, I only, yeah.
- I prefer to use
headphones every other time.
- I don't, like yeah,
to me like, headphones,
I don't know why,
I think it might be because I have like,
jaw problems or something.
Like if I wear headphones for too long
it just like really starts to
put pressure on my jaw and stuff.
But like yeah, with earphones,
and like, this is going above the tech,
but like, there are certain things like,
earphones, sunglasses where,
I try to buy the cheapest possible
because I've gone through too many.
Or you know, like,
sometimes you buy like,
I remember buying like one ...
- What like, at the end of
every day you're like, crack!
All right, next one!
- No yeah, because like,
sometimes I misplace them,
but especially with sunglasses, right?
It's so easy to misplace sunglasses,
especially 'cause you wear them out.
And sometimes you don't
always have your case on you
or sometimes you, you know-
- [Joey] You don't have a bag or anything.
- You take 'em off and you like,
clip them on your shirt
and they just fall off sometimes.
I've had that happen too many
times, and with earphones,
sometimes you misplace them or you like,
forget that they're in your
jean pockets or something.
- So the headphones kinda
make you uncomfortable
'cause they like, put
pressure on your head.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- It's the same thing
for me and the keyboard
and the wrist though.
It hurts my wrist if I
have to use that flat thing
for ages.
- [Joey] Right.
- 'Cause your wrist is like, why?
Why are we doing this?
Also, I'm like paranoid about getting
any wrist injuries-
- Like carpal tunnel and stuff.
- Yeah 'cause I, you know, I wanna game.
- Well you game way more than us.
- Yeah, so I ...
- That's a legitimate
concern for you, isn't it?
- I'm very cautious about
like, wrist injuries.
So I want the most ergonomic
setup all the time.
- Why don't you get those
like, wrist guard things then?
I've seen a couple streamers wear them.
- Yeah, I mean that's ...
They normally have that
on when it's too late.
And they've already like, done the damage.
- I know some people who have it on like,
to actually just prevent
it from happening-
- I mean if you have a good setup,
you shouldn't need that.
- Right, but you know,
even people with good
setups can sometimes,
you know, game a little too hard.
- But like headphones like,
for me it's like, I can't
have the in-ear ones,
'cause every single in-ear headphones
for some reason wants to like,
excavate your ear, and
get really in there.
And that hurts the shit out of my ears.
So I can't use those.
- It's probably because
you don't have like,
the right size buds, right?
- Yeah, I have one that
comes with a bunch of
replaceable ones, but even then like,
AirPods unironically are the
ones that I like the most,
'cause they don't really
go in your ear much.
- Yeah, they kinda like, sit on top of it.
- That's what I like the most,
but I don't use Apple,
so I don't have them.
And that's why I use
like the over ear ones.
Also the sound's way nicer.
- I only use the over ear ones
if it's like in the winter,
because it also like, keeps my head warm.
But like, in the summer here especially,
I'm just like, no headphones, go away.
- I actually always use them.
I'm ...
- Dude, like I've seen you like,
walking in like, the Japanese
summer with headphones on,
I'm like, bro, that looks painful.
- That is dedication there.
- I don't know, that's
just how I like listening!
That's the comfort.
- I mean your headphones
have taken a fucking beating.
It's like, I remember
seeing it and it's like-
- [Joey] It's like falling apart!
- It's like falling apart,
man, like holy shit!
- I'm like, dude, buy
some new headphones, dude!
- Well it's 'cause ...
It's 'cause I'm waiting for the,
right now I'm using the Sony WX1003,
worst naming system of all time.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah.
- What the fuck is going on?
Sort it out.
- String of numbers and letters.
- And then like the next one, the fours,
isn't really a significant upgrade.
- Yeah.
- And I'm hoping that the fives,
when they ever come out,
which I don't even know if they will,
are like a decent upgrade.
So I'm kind of in that
weird spot where it's like,
they're broken, and they're
not working properly.
- Yeah.
- But like, because they're like,
you know, $300 headphones.
- Yeah.
- I want them to last like, five years.
- Yeah of course, of course.
- So, if I buy the fours now
and then the fives come
out and they're like,
the most best upgrade and you
can hear God through them.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna be really pissed
off that I bought these fours.
And I didn't just wait a few months extra.
But I don't even know if it's coming out.
They haven't even
announced it or anything,
so I'm just waiting, kinda hoping.
- You're waiting for something
you don't know it's gonna come out.
- The one side is completely broken
so it keeps falling out.
- Yeah.
- Just duct tape that shit.
- I thought about it.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey,
the easy way to save when
shopping on your iPhone
or computer.
- Joey, how do you feel
about shopping online?
- I feel positively.
I feel it's the only way the Zoomers shop.
- But you know one thing
about shopping online?
How many times has a promo
code just taunted you
when you were at the checkout?
- I just don't wanna be
missing out on deals!
- [Joey] Lads, Honey is
the free shopping tool
that scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones
it finds to your cart.
Let me tell you how it works, okay?
- Oh my god!
- Tell me!
- [Joey] I'll tell you exactly
how it works, all right?
Imagine you're shopping
on one of your favorite sites, all right?
- All right.
- Okay.
- [Joey] Okay, when
you go to the checkout,
the Honey button appears,
and all you have to do is
to click Apply Coupons.
Wait a few seconds as
Honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site,
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll just watch the prices drop!
- You know guys, now
that we're in England,
we gotta buy plenty of tea.
And thanks to Honey, I saved 20 pounds!
I'm basically robbing
from the Queen herself!
- So if you don't already have Honey,
you could be straight up
missing out on free deals,
and by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and supporting us, the boys!
And get Honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
- It's win-win, guys.
It's win-win.
- Back to the episode.
- Okay, you're the gamer, right?
You talked about keyboards, right?
144 hertz monitors.
- All right.
Okay, if you genuinely
think there's no difference
between a 60 and 144 hertz you're a clown.
- Is there a point, if you don't play FPS.
- Yeah!
- 'Cause I genuinely like,
because we have in the
office, I've never used them.
- You notice it more with FPS games.
But like, even normal games,
that are not like, locked to 60,
look way better in 144.
- I think that's the problem.
I only play games that are locked to 60.
- Because you're on the Switch.
- Yeah.
- If you actually game on your PC,
144 hertz is way, it looks
way better than, I don't know.
I'd rather have 144 hertz than like,
a more like, higher resolution.
- Right.
- For me it's way nicer and smoother.
And it just looks good.
I don't know why.
Resolution after-
- It's milky!
- After like 2k, I can't
fucking tell the difference.
Like ...
- Yeah!
- I, 4k games-
- Especially on a monitor, yeah.
- Barely look any different from 2k to me.
But I feel way more difference
from 60 to 120 hertz,
144 hertz.
- Yeah, 'cause I feel
the difference with FPS,
I just don't play FPS.
- Yeah yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah, same.
- So I was just like,
what are the game types,
would really like, really
make me feel the difference?
Because I'm already ...
- Minecraft.
- Any game where you're, you know,
you're moving around, you're
controlling a character moving.
- Minecraft's probably
the only one where I've
probably like, somewhat slightly seen it.
- Right.
- You just notice it's just more fluid!
- It looks kinda smooth.
- And you'll notice when
you go back that it's like,
not quite the same.
It's not bad.
It's not like, you know,
if you haven't got a lot of money, right?
And you're choosing between like,
a better PC, or like,
a monitor that makes you
like, (indistinct) instantly,
then just get a better PC.
Get better parts or something, right?
Like, it's kinda like the cherry on top.
But there's no point buying a monster PC
if you're then not also gonna
get a good monitor for it.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- 'Cause you're basically buying like,
an engine with a car that can't fit it.
It's like, okay well, I mean.
It's, you know, a lot of
people will have like,
3080s and still use 60 FPS monitors,
and I'm like ...
(chuckling)
Why?
You've put like, rockets on a scooter!
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It's like, it's just too much.
Like you're overpowering it.
I don't know, I mean,
I game a lot, so I guess I ...
- I mean, I am that guy
who has a 3080 and ...
- No you don't fucking ...
- And uses 60 FPS, but like,
that's because it's like a
fucking monster to render
when I'm editing.
That's my thought.
- Yeah, that's true.
- Yeah, same same.
- That's the only other like, I think,
if you're not gaming,
if you're doing industry stuff.
- I definitely use it like
that more than the gaming.
- Yeah.
- Like I've definitely noticed like
a massive massive difference
with rendering and editing.
Like, that's like, I don't
need 60 FPS to edit, you know?
- If you're streaming,
it's also very good.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Because the NVIDIA cards
have dedicated video chips
that are completely
separate to the gaming.
So you can game and
stream at the same time
and it doesn't affect the performance.
It does a little bit.
That's just 'cause they
have other things going on.
- What do you think about,
so do you care about the
keyboard thonk then? Like ...
- I mean ...
- The ASMR sounds?
- The ASMR sounds.
- Yeah, I do.
I mean, I like what I have right now.
Maybe I should,
(indistinct) can remind
me to record something,
I don't know.
I'll probably forget.
- He's gonna play an ASMR of his keys!
- It's just like, I don't
know, it's a nice click!
It's a really nice click. It's subtle.
- 'Cause like, I'm on the fence right now,
because I'm gonna be
getting my custom keyboard
within like a few months,
so maybe I'm gonna be like,
"Man, Connor was right this entire time."
- Couple months from now,
you're gonna be on that side!
- Yeah yeah yeah!
'Cause like, I remember
going on this video,
and just looking at the comments section,
and I'm just like ...
I've seen less horny comments
on Pornhub comments, you know?
Like, my god like, I literally feel like
everyone is cumming from
like the sound of these keys,
and I'm just like ...
That's a nice sounding key, I guess.
- It's weird 'cause it's
like, it feels like,
almost like PlayDoh-y at first,
'cause you're so used to
the really harsh clicks.
- Yeah.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Of other ones, and it feels like,
"Ooh, it's really like,
squishy and soft."
- [Joey] Like wet.
- Yeah.
- But then after a while,
you get used to it and you're like,
"Oh no, this is actually
like, really firm."
Or the clicks are really solid.
But they're not like,
in your fucking face.
It's not like it's screaming,
"Hey, you just clicked me!
Hey, hey you just clicked it!"
'Cause you don't wanna be that
asshole on Discord who's like,
click click click click click!
- Yeah, because I remember
when mechanical keyboards
got popularized, and that
was like the popular key.
- Because it was like,
everyone bought the $30
mechanical keyboard on Amazon,
'cause they thought
mechanical equaled good.
When in fact mechanical was just ...
It was loud as shit.
- I just can't get over like,
you describing like
the sound of these keys
and you know, it just sounds like,
you know, hearing the
experience of someone
going on a drug I've
never been on, you know?
It's just like, "At first
it's like really wet,
but then once you get used to
it it gets like really firm,
and it's like ..."
- [Connor] It's true, it is true.
- That's when the euphoria hits you.
- [Man] It's the (indistinct).
- Yeah!
- It's the lube!
- Like they're in the, 'cause like-
- I lube my fingers when I'm using it.
- [Joey] Yeah yeah.
- 'Cause when I was picking the keys,
'cause like, I'll take a picture
and send it to you (indistinct)
but like, I have like
a whole fucking like-
- [Joey] Test keyboard.
- It's a test, it's a square of just keys,
of different keys,
and like, it's,
it's bad for someone with ADHD,
'cause it's just like,
you're just like constantly poking it,
and you're just like, "Ooh,
this just feels nice."
- This is a fun toy!
- Ooh this is a fun toy, this is!
It's like, fidget spinners
got nothing on this!
And then you have to like click one,
and then you have to choose
one key from like, 100.
I'm like, at some points,
like, keys just like, meld together.
And there are like, different like,
the different like,
lubeness of keys and like,
I didn't know lubeness like,
mattered with keyboard keys.
Like I'm just like, okay.
At which point, I'm like,
I get it, it's like a hobby, right?
It's a hobby kind of object, right?
Because you have to be really into it
to really care about it this much.
- A key-phile.
- Yeah, a key-phile, right?
At which point does it get like, too much?
Where ...
- Yeah.
- Where it's ...
- Never too much.
- Is it never too much?
- It's never too much.
- All right. I'm waiting, I'm waiting.
I'm waiting for my first custom keyboard.
- People are like, this is why
we're gonna have flying cars.
- They're the ones that are
gonna invent a flying car.
- People get too invested in this.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Someone told me, I
was streaming yesterday.
I was like, completely unrelated,
but you said ADHD so,
it came up in my mind.
I was like, "No no no, I checked,"
'cause chat was accusing
me of having ADHD.
And I was like, "No, I don't have ADHD."
- [Joey] What?
- I was like, "I can focus on things.
I get really fixated on things."
And they're like, "You
know focusing too much
is a sign of ADHD, right?"
And I was like, "What?"
- Yeah.
- And apparently it is.
So I was like, wait what,
so if I concentrate too much on things ...
- You have ADHD.
- But if I don't concentrate
enough I have ADHD too?
- Yup.
- I'm like wait, what, hold up!
What does that mean?
What does that ... how does that work?
- I don't know, it's like,
you can't be on too far of
either side of the spectrum.
- [Connor] Yeah yeah.
- 'Cause then you have
a problem, apparently.
- I guess, 'cause it doesn't specify
that you can't pay attention.
It's attention deficit disorder,
so you've got too much
attention or too little.
But I was just like, what?
- Yeah.
- Who's making these rules up, huh?
I don't know ...
- People have ADHD, I guess.
- People who are more informed than us!
- Yeah.
I was like, god damn these people!
Coming up with these definitions.
I'm like, that's crazy.
- It's usually the person
that says you have ADHD.
Like, officially.
- How do you test if someone
concentrates too much?
How do you test ... I'm genuinely curious.
- [Man] It's basically like
you can't control yourself
and you realize that,
"Oh shit, it's like ..."
- Oh, you get lost in something?
Oh, I see I see.
- [Man] So you get obsessed with-
- That's kinda (indistinct).
- [Man] Yeah, it is, but at the same time,
it's like, you can't control it.
- But I feel there's a lot of people like
in just this internet age that, you know,
because we're so fucking over-sensitized
and just overwhelmed with
all this fucking information, right,
all at the same time, right.
There are so many people
who are just like,
"Oh, there's so much fucking
shit to do on the internet!
Do I have ADHD?"
I'm like, no, you're just on the internet.
- Yeah, sometimes I wonder,
I'm like, I don't think like,
I have a problem.
I think there's just so
much shit that's being
shoved in my face.
- Yeah! That's what it is!
- Sometimes. I don't know.
- But that's why like, I
reckon there's probably,
I mean like ...
- I don't know, I mean, you have ADHD.
How does it feel?
- I mean, I got ... it is weird, right,
because the reason ...
I only like recently
got diagnosed with ADHD
and it was just like the most
ah-hah moment of my life.
Like, of course I do!
You know?
- Like, oh, that's what that was!
- Yeah! Because like, you know,
especially like growing
up in Asian culture,
mental health and mental conditions
are very like-
- [Joey] Don't exist!
- Literally that meme image
of, "Just don't be sad."
Like ...
- Yeah yeah!
- Cutting the water faucet.
- Yeah, turning the water off, like-
- Don't be sad.
So I remember like,
'cause I have this like,
such a vivid memory in school, right?
Of, I knew someone in school who
got diagnosed with ADHD and they got like,
some like advantage or something in like,
a test that we were taking, right?
They got like, extra time or something.
And I remember like describing like,
what his experience of ADHD was,
and I was just like,
"What a fucking liar!"
Like, "What a fucking liar! I do that!
And he's getting some
free time on an exam!
What the fuck?"
And it just like, 'cause
like it just didn't,
it just, for some reason,
it just never fucking occurred to me,
that unfortunately I
had the same symptoms,
because I was raised ...
not even raised, but like,
a lot of people in my culture
and the environment I grew up with,
it was just, we were,
it was put in our minds that, you know,
mental health just wasn't really like,
it was either like a
very very serious thing,
or it just like, was, just didn't exist.
And then you've just gotta
get on with your day, right?
- Like there's no such thing
as a mild symptom, right?
- Yeah yeah yeah!
- It's like you either had
it or you don't have it.
- So what made you think,
"Oh, I should go and see if I have it."
Like, what was the turning point?
Like what ...
- This is gonna be awful.
Enough comments on Trash Taste.
- No way! Are you serious?
- Mentioning it. I am actually serious.
- Wait, why?
'Cause you were like,
fidgeting with things?
- Huh?
- 'Cause you were fidgeting with things?
- Honestly, seeing myself
on camera, I'm just like ...
Damn, man, I do that shit? What?
But yeah. Because like, obviously
I've never been on camera,
and especially with me being
on camera documented so much
on Trash Taste, I'm like,
damn, I do a lot of weird shit!
- So people psychoanalyze us all the time.
- Like I understand-
- We start to notice habits, right?
- Yeah yeah yeah.
I started to notice habits,
'cause you're looking at yourself
through the third person.
And then also, you know,
there's always gonna be
comments that are like,
psychoanalyzing and over-analyzing stuff.
- Oh yeah, people say
some really wild shit.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
But then like, I saw some
comments that are just like,
fuck, they kind of make sense,
and then I Googled it.
Google what they say, I'm like damn,
that doesn't look like it's just someone
talking out their ass.
And then like the final straw
was meeting someone here who has ADHD
and they described their
symptoms, I'm like ...
Fuck, okay.
I need to go get diagnosed.
I need to go get checked out.
And yeah, it was thanks
to Trash Taste, I guess,
and thanks to random YouTube comments.
- Well done guys!
You're like, it's like the
one time in the world where
you guys were actually
correct with your diagnosis.
And you weren't just a bunch of like,
Reddit armchair psychologists.
- I've seen some wild ones.
I see some wild diagnoses.
- Yeah, I do. I have as well.
- In a few years of Trash Taste.
- That's not an excuse to
psychoanalyze all of us, okay?
A broken clock is right
two times, you know guys?
(laughing)
- I remember my, fucking,
when I was growing up,
everyone was like, convinced
I had like, dyslexia.
- Yeah.
- And like, I was like,
"No, I don't think I do.
'Cause I don't really have
a problem reading the words.
I just really fucking hate doing it."
- Right.
- But, 'cause they would
describe the symptoms to me
as like a, you know like,
when I was like 10 or something.
So to give some back story to this,
I went to a Welsh school.
I didn't like reading.
I liked gaming.
I was probably-
- Gamer from birth.
- My parents probably wished that
nobody had ever introduced me to gaming.
But I was introduced to
gaming very very young.
We're talking like, four, five, six.
- Oh wow.
- I found out about video games.
And I became like, obsessed.
And I read the games.
I mean, I've said this before,
I beat all of,
like one of the first games I ever played
was Pokemon Gold in French,
and I beat the whole game in French.
I don't know how.
- Even though you don't know any French.
- Yeah, this must have been literally
the birth of me bashing
my head against the walls
to figure out shit in
video games, not reading.
So I've been doing this
since like a young age.
I never really, like, read stuff.
I just kind of did it.
This is probably like, sounds very like,
monkey-esque already,
and not, you know,
not very intelligent.
- It's very like, a primeval like-
- Yeah, it is.
And I went to a Welsh school.
So I didn't really read
English, like ever.
We learned everything in Welsh.
I spoke in Welsh in school.
So I never read English, like ever.
The only thing I'd ever read is like,
we go to the store, I can read the,
I would just read the fucking-
- [Joey] Bread.
- Yeah, bread, whatever like.
But like, when I would be quizzed on like,
how to spell shit, I like, wouldn't know.
They'd be like, "Spell said,"
and I'd be like, "Oh yeah,
just Z. Z-E-D, innit? Said."
I'd be like, I don't know.
- Your.
- Yeah. So like, this is from
like age eight or whatever.
Like, I was fucking awful.
And so when we started
learning English more,
I was like, yeah,
I just don't read books, ever.
And they're like, "What?
You don't read books?"
And my parents were
like, "Yeah, we tried to!
We tried to make him read, he wouldn't."
- But he keeps playing
those goddamn video games!
- To be fair, like,
my parents tried their goddamn
hardest to get me to read.
It was just not gonna happen.
Like I was just, I had
absolutely zero interest in it.
So I was so so bad at English.
But like, they knew I was very competent
at all other subjects.
Like I was very like, you know,
maths and science and all that,
really really high marks,
like I was, you know,
I mean I got like A-star and
shit in maths and all that,
it's like the highest grade you can get.
I went and did engineering and all that.
So there's no problem with like,
I wasn't like, bad at learning.
It was just, I just
hated this one subject.
But they were convinced, they were like,
"Well if he's competent in other stuff,
he just must have some
dyslexia or something."
And they would tell me
what the symptoms were.
And it was so annoying, because as a kid,
this is where I started learning where
adults like, fuck with you as a kid.
They would like try and
spoon-feed me the answers to like,
to dyslexia.
- Right.
- They would like, try
and tell me I had symptoms
that I didn't have.
- And to like, get you to agree to it?
- Just because they wanted to have like,
so they can tick it off as like,
"Oh, we've figured it out.
We'll sort him out."
And then whenever I have any issues,
they'd be like, "God, don't worry,
we don't have to put in more work.
He's just dyslexic."
You know what I mean? Kinda?
This is where you like ...
I get it, 'cause the teachers,
they want an answer.
They want a reason.
- They wanted a solution, right?
- They wanna know why,
and I can understand,
everyone wants a reason why, but like,
unfortunately mental
health and shit like that
and learning is like,
the most complicated shit known to man.
And there is never ever just
a one solution that fits all.
- Yeah like, just because
somebody sucks at something,
it doesn't mean there's
an inherent problem
with them, right?
- So I would like, talk
to my teachers and stuff,
and I remember talking
to my English teacher
and she like, made me like,
stay after class and she'd talk to me,
and she'd be like,
"So, you can read these words, right?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I can read them."
She's like, "They don't
look like messed up or
jumbled at all?"
And I was like, "No, not really."
And then she was like,
"Sometimes the words are hard to read,"
I'm like, "Yeah, I don't
know the word sometimes.
'Cause I don't really know it.
So it's kind of hard to read,
'cause English is kinda funny
and the pronunciation is weird."
And then, so she was like,
"Hmm, okay okay."
So then another teacher
came in a few weeks later
and started asking me more questions
about dyslexia and stuff.
And I was like, "The words
are not fucking jumbled, okay?
I've seen the movies, they
don't fucking do that!"
And I know that's not how
it works, but I'm like,
"I do not have a problem!
I can see all the letters in order!
They do not move, I know what I'm reading!
I am just shit at this subject,
and I don't like it!"
- They just like, start
shaking your body like,
"What about now?"
- Yeah, yeah.
It was literally like,
thank god I wasn't a kid
that would just like,
and I felt bad, 'cause like,
kids are so easily like,
pushed into saying yes or no.
I'm so glad I was a stubborn
fuck from like a young age.
Where I was like, "No!
The words are not jumbled!
I don't have a problem reading the words,
I just hate this shitty subject!
I hate English!"
And they were like, "No no no no no!
You have to be! You have to
have a disability or something!"
- You got this fucked!
- You must be! You must be!
- Yeah, you must be!
- I'm very glad that, I
don't know where I got
the stubbornness from, but I was glad!
'Cause like, I remember like,
it was really annoying.
And they kept insisting I had it.
I'm like, no! No!
- [Joey] It's like, stop!
- I do not have this!
I have no problem reading Of Mice and Men!
I just don't like it!
I'd rather watch the movie!
- They're like, tryna just
like brainwash you, right?
- Okay. So this is what I'm realizing.
And I understand now why like,
you know, this whole discussion
about diagnosing kids
is like, I get why it's
like a touchy subject.
Some parents are like, "My
kids! You can't diagnose them!"
And then, you know, some people
are so quick to jump to it.
It's a really uncomfortable
subject and kind of touchy,
'cause the kids often
can't, like I was a kid.
I couldn't fully express that, you know,
I can't just be like, listen,
I didn't really connect with
the subject, I don't like it.
- [Joey] Yeah, they can't
fend for themselves, right?
- Yeah. I can't really fully explain
why I don't want to, why
I don't engage with this.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But they'd, you know, they're just like-
- But they're like, "No, we're the adults.
We know more than you."
- Right, right!
So it's kind of a ... it's weird, man.
And I think that's why like,
when you get parents that
are super passionate about it
and stuff, and then there's
also the thing of like,
some parents don't want to
get their kids diagnosed with things.
'Cause they don't wanna like, be like,
"My kid has a problem,"
or has something, right?
My parents didn't really give a shit.
They were like, "If he's got
it, he's got it. Whatever."
Like, just deal with it, but yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I think with
how mental health is now,
it's just like, it feels like,
at least it feels like,
if you're diagnosed with something,
then the kinda feeling is,
"Oh, there's something wrong with me,"
or something like that.
You know, there's
something broken with me.
'Cause like, with me
and ADHD, for example.
Like, I didn't realize that
I was abnormal, you know?
Because I would have, I
would do all of these things,
to basically be able to like,
seem like I was able
to function, you know?
And I'd only learned recently that
that was like my coping
mechanisms for like my
whatever, like how my
brain works, you know?
I had figured out ways to live with it.
And I thought everyone had to do that.
You know, that's just what I thought.
And like, especially with like,
after being diagnosed, it hasn't like,
changed my life or anything like that.
It's like, the biggest
thing that it's done for me,
is like, it's just helped
me understand myself.
And I think that's just,
I think that's like the
most valuable thing.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right?
- Definitely.
- Sure. It makes sense of
things that you were like,
"Why? Why am I like this?"
- Yeah yeah yeah! Exactly!
'Cause it's just helped me like,
deal with it even more.
'Cause I just remembered,
because it wasn't just the
YouTube comments as well.
I remember specifically
seeing this one YouTube video,
and that was like the last
straw, where it was like-
- Dr. Mike diagnosed me.
- No no, where it was like,
where it was like, "What ADHD feels like,"
and someone like, edited
a video of their day,
and like, edited it in a way to like
show how they perceived the world.
- Like thoughts and-
- Yeah, how they perceived the world.
And it was like, such a one for one copy
of how I see the world, I was just like,
"Oh my god."
Like, that was like the ah-hah moment.
'Cause I think there was
one scene in particular,
'cause he was going about his day,
and he was like, being
scolded by his teacher
or his mum or something.
And he was like, fidgeting, right?
He was fidgeting.
And he would get told off for that.
Because his mum or his teacher,
I can't remember who it was exactly,
but they were just like,
"Can you concentrate, please?
I'm trying to tell you something serious,
and you're doing something else!"
And I'm just like, and he said,
"Oh, but it helps me to concentrate."
And I'm just like, that's
been my entire life!
That's been, it like,
I need to fidget with something
in order to concentrate,
and if I don't, I just lose like,
my trail of thought or something, right?
- He's just like me!
- Yeah! I was just like, holy shit.
Maybe I should fucking
go in and get this done.
- So wait, so how do they ...
'Cause I've always been curious, like,
when you go see a doctor, right,
and you wanna like, you know,
figure out if you are
actually diagnosed with it.
How does the doctor like, check that?
- Well-
- Is there like a test?
- He just puts like a
Rubik's cube on the table
and he's like ...
- It's like, "I'll be back in 15 minutes."
- Puts like a fidget spinner on the table.
- What do you think about this?
- Yeah no, 'cause I've
always been curious like,
you know, how does the doctor like,
kind of determine whether
you actually have ADHD
or if it's just like something
similar to that that's not
necessarily ADHD, right?
- Yeah I mean, at the moment I'm at like,
I'm still like processing
it and learning through it.
'Cause at the moment, at
the beginning they take you
and they do like this just,
it's a survey first.
So it's like the first test.
Then afterwards, if you tick enough boxes
to be like, "Oh okay, there's, you know-"
- A chance, yeah.
- There's a chance, then you
go in to the psychologist
and you know, they ask you like,
a bunch of questions.
For me at least.
I don't know, because like,
another friend in England just recently
got diagnosed with ADHD as well,
and I think in England
they have a different kind of process.
- It's probably different
to every country.
- Yeah yeah, I think it's
different to every country.
In England I believe there's like a,
you have to go to like
a group session as well,
or something like that.
- Oh.
- It's different in every country,
but for me it was more
just a one on one talk
with my, you know, with the-
- The psychologist.
- The psychologist, where
they just asked me like,
very detailed questions about
my experiences, how I perceive events.
And like, I can't remember everything,
'cause there was like a
lot of fucking questions,
but it was kinda,
it was basically like a therapy session
where it was just like,
"So tell me about this experience."
- [Joey] Talk me through it.
- Talk to me about this.
Tell me about that.
And yeah, I mean,
ever since being diagnosed,
I've like, like I said,
my life hasn't changed that much.
I just know now, it's
like written in paper,
that this is-
- You got the plaque now.
- No no, I got the plaque of just like,
"Here's how your brain works,
and here's why your brain does this shit."
- Yeah.
- And ever since knowing that, I'm like,
"Oh, that makes sense!"
Now I have like a word
to put to how I felt for
a lot of my life.
And yeah, that's it like,
that's the thing.
I feel a lot of people,
a lot of people maybe have, you know,
maybe have different conditions
or different mental conditions
that they've just never
really thought about.
Because, like me,
maybe you found a way to
cope with it day to day,
you know, because like me,
maybe you thought that,
"Hey, maybe everyone's like this!"
And then you've just found
a way to live normally
because you've grown up.
You've grown up in an environment where
you just need to like, just
get on with it, basically.
And a lot of the times like,
not every mental condition is just like,
on the extreme end.
Sometimes it's like, really really subtle.
But if you've ever like,
had a thought that,
"Maybe I do have this,"
or, "Maybe I do have that."
I think it might be worth
just talking to someone.
Not to like, have like a
life-changing ah-ha moment,
but just learning more about yourself
I feel like is the most valuable thing
that someone can do.
And ... doesn't mean
that there's necessarily
anything wrong with you, you know?
- I think more people would probably go
if it was like, easier to get seen.
- Yeah, definitely.
- (indistinct), right, it's like.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- You gotta be either rich
or have a lot of time on your hands.
Or both.
- Or both.
- To get anything done, healthcare wise,
or mental health wise.
I know in the UK it's not too great.
I know they're like,
trying to get better at it,
but I know it's not adequate.
- Yeah, in the UK it's like
the waiting list is like,
it's fucking, like huge.
- No kidding.
- Yeah, because yeah,
because I feel like the biggest problem,
especially like, everywhere
but America I can see,
is like, access to mental
healthcare is difficult as hell.
Especially in Asia.
- In Japan, dude! It's like ...
- Oh my god! In Japan ...
- Half the time it's
just like, nonexistent.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Mental health in Japan
is the (indistinct).
There is no ...
(laughing)
It's like, go to the pub,
drink a beer, and don't think about it.
- It's like, I know why you're sad!
It's because you're not drunk right now.
Go to an izikaya. Have a couple of beers.
You'll be all right.
And it's just, no.
- I'm just like, I was walking home,
and I saw a guy just like, on the floor.
He was crying.
In Tokyo, and I was like,
"Why is like, no one helping him?"
Like, loads of people
just walking past him,
like, why is no one saying like,
"Hey, are you okay?"
It's just so weird to me!
I was like, what?
People were just like,
"Man, I don't wanna ...
Don't wanna get involved."
- Yeah, they don't.
That's the thing.
- [Connor] That's so fucking sad.
- They see, 'cause you know, again.
Collectivist society,
they see one, you know,
cog that's out of the
system, and they're like,
"Well, that's not our problem.
We just gotta keep the system moving."
- Well the UK isn't great, but I think,
at least where I was from,
if someone was like, crying in the street,
like everyone would be
like, "Are you okay?"
- Oh yeah!
- Yeah yeah yeah!
- I'd say most English-speaking countries
there would definitely be
at least a couple people
being like, "Hey, you all
right dude? What's up?"
- At least like, someone checking on them.
- Yeah! Exactly.
And you know, not to say that Japan isn't,
you know, the fucking
cruel mistress of the world
in that sense, right?
Like there's definitely people,
I've seen people, you know,
go up to strangers and be like, you know.
(speaks foreign language)
- I wanted to help, but I was like,
I don't want this to be a awkward
language barrier situation
where you actually need help
but I'm just like,
(speaks foreign language).
You know?
I felt so sad about that,
I couldn't do anything to help this dude.
'Cause I was like, I don't know,
just imagining what situations
he could be going through
made him so fucking sad.
I was like, what if his parents like,
said he couldn't go home or something.
I don't fucking know, I was like,
ugh, fuck it!
- [Joey] Yeah man.
- Yeah. I just wanted to add
an addendum to what I said.
If you do, like,
I think a big issue
nowadays as well is like,
there's a lot of self-diagnoses.
Like, especially, I've seen
it on TikTok especially.
- The internet doctors.
- Like, they're like, I've
read one Google article.
I am, like, you know,
I'm like, I got this ADHD,
or I'm like ...
- Well it's almost like
the, what's the word?
The like collection of, you know,
people kind of, say what you will,
but online they kinda see
it as like a badge of honor.
Sometimes.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah!
- Yeah yeah yeah!
- Some people do.
They're like, "If I have XX
thing and I have it in my bio,
I'm like, I'm part of a group."
- You get brownie points.
- It's weird!
- Or you're like, immune to like,
sometimes like being an
asshole or something.
You know?
- Yeah yeah yeah!
- Like it's just like, I don't know.
It sucks, 'cause you don't wanna be like,
"Man, people are faking it."
But it's like, there are people faking it!
- [Joey] No, there are.
- People see it as like a
badge of honor in a way.
That's like, what?
- [Joey] And you know, even if you-
- Even if you're proud about it!
You could be proud about
it and be open about it.
But like-
- Exactly.
- Is it like, self ...
- [Joey] But like, don't
be a dick about it.
- Yeah, self-diagnosing so that you can
then go and brag about it
online is like, what the fuck?
- Yeah.
- People actually have
to deal with this shit!
- Yeah yeah, I know right? It ...
- And then that whole
argument comes into like,
"Well, we couldn't
afford to go to a doctor
and get actual diagnosis,"
and it's like, yeah but you probably,
still should never diagnose.
I don't think anyone ever would
recommend you self-diagnose.
- No no no, you could be
completely wrong about that.
- Especially with something as delicate,
and as complicated as mental health!
'Cause it's like, like I said,
the mind is a complicated thing.
And people do weird
shit a lot of the times,
and you can never know
unless you really see
like an expert, you know?
- But then it also sucks as well,
'cause then you see an expert
and maybe the expert was
shit at his job or something,
you know? So ...
It's always just like
a fucking minefield of-
- Yeah yeah.
- Like, like.
- Counterarguments.
- Have you ever like, had
a bad experience with like
a doctor or anything like that?
- Yeah, I've had doctors where I'm like,
"Yo, this thing is actually
like, fucking hurting me."
And then he's like, "Oh no, it's good."
And I'll be like, "What? Bro,
no, I'm in like some bad ...
It's a bit of pain."
And he's like, "No, you're good."
And then I go to another
doctor and he's like,
"Oh holy shit man, you got a,
this is like, you gotta sort this out."
- I've had a lot of
instances where I go to like
a local doctor, or like a
local GM and they'll be like,
"I'll refer you to a bigger hospital."
After looking at it for like two seconds.
And then you go to the bigger hospital
and they're like,
"Oh. Here's some drugs
you can get anywhere."
I'm like, why did the guy at the local GM
not do that instead of
fucking wasting my time
taking me to another bigger hospital
that's way further away,
to do the exact same job
that he could have done?
You know? So ...
It's probably the only one I've had.
- Yeah because, especially me like,
right now I'm like,
I think my biggest 30s like health thing
that I've found somewhat
is like my jaw issue.
And so I've been like,
trying to get someone,
I've been trying to find an expert
to help me sort it out, so,
you know, I go to the
dentist, to try and like,
try and find out what's
wrong with my jaw, right?
And so, like,
I remember the first time I've
tried to get it sorted out
was, I remember when I went to like,
several dentists in the UK.
And one of them said,
"Oh, do you still have your wisdom teeth?"
And they were like, and I was like,
"Yeah, I still have my wisdom teeth.
But like, they're not like,
the spacing in it isn't,
like it isn't bad or anything.
It's not like, hurting me
or anything like that."
And they were like,
"Yeah, we recommend you
get that taken out."
And I was like, okay.
Do I, that's a big commitment, you know?
Because you know, at the time,
I was still a YouTuber.
So you know-
- You can't talk.
- You can't talk for a while.
- You can't talk, you can't talk,
so I like, I wanted to make sure that
I needed to go through this procedure.
So I went to a second
dentist for a second opinion.
And he was like,
"No, definitely don't take
your wisdom teeth out.
That's not the issue.
Here, have this mouthguard."
And I was like, okay.
He gave me the mouthguard.
It like, improved it a little bit,
but like the problem still persisted,
so I went back to him,
and he's like, "Yeah, honestly,
maybe you need braces or something?
That's gonna cost like
30,000 pounds or something."
I was like, okay.
Let's be sure I need to go through this!
So like, at this point,
I'd moved to Japan, right?
And then come to Japan.
I do the same thing, go to the dentist,
and they were like,
"You don't need to take
your wisdom teeth out
but maybe just take the
top wisdom teeth out."
And I'm just like, I'm getting like a,
like every dentist I've gone to so far
has given me a different opinion about
what needs to be done!
So I'm like, who do I listen to?
- And you go to another one and it's like,
so you only need to remove
half your wisdom teeth.
Just like the top half, just
like shave it off a little.
- [Garnt] Yeah yeah yeah.
- Just shave the top off
and you'll be all right.
- Yeah, I'm just like, it's so like,
I wanna get it fixed,
but I just, it's scary because,
whatever I go through,
it's a big commitment obviously
in time and cost, and it's my body.
I wanna make sure it's done right.
But at the same time, everyone I say,
everyone I meet is telling
me different things.
So I have no fucking clue
who to listen to, basically.
- I got like tonsillitis like,
I used to get it like every year.
- Right.
- And they were like,
"Just remove your tonsils."
And I was like, aw I don't know,
I don't really want ...
'Cause they say there's a chance
it can like affect your voice.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, I'd rather
just be sick once a year
and have like a lot of pain.
- Well you haven't had it
in a while though, right?
- No, luckily I haven't had it in a while.
Like I don't think I've had it in Japan.
- Right.
- Luckily.
But yeah, I used to
get it like every year.
It was a pain in the ass.
I just didn't want my voice to change!
I was like, I like my voice right now.
It's kind of important to my job.
What if I change it and ...
- Although they say like,
you know, you'll have a chance
that the voice will change,
but it's not like you're gonna be like,
(in high pitched voice)
"Hey guys, what's up?"
(in normal voice) You know?
- I know I know, I was just like,
I have learned how to use my voice.
- Yeah.
- For like voice acting.
Very specific, like,
I can feel it-
- I guess you don't wanna
like, relearn it, right?
- I don't know how it would feel.
I don't ... they just
told me there's a chance
it could change slightly,
and I was like ...
For me, it's just not worth it.
I was like, I'll just be
sick every now and then.
- I'll take the sickness.
- [Connor] Like, I'll just be sick.
- Tonsillitis isn't real.
- It's not an illness!
- It's a mindset!
(laughing)
- It's a lifestyle!
- That shit fucking sucks!
Have you had that? Have
you got yours removed?
- Yeah yeah.
- No, I still have mine.
- I still have mine, yeah, as well.
- Oh dude, when you get
it, it fucking hurt.
Have you ever had it?
- Yeah, I've had it.
- No.
- It's horrible.
- Never had it.
- It was fucking horrible.
- Your voice, your like
throat closes up so much.
And it feels like it's like,
you know there's like fucking squishy toys
where you put your finger in it?
That's how I imagine
your throat looks like.
- Ew!
- [Connor] It's horrible. It's so gross.
- That sounds gross, yeah.
No thank you.
- It's not that bad. It's just your voice.
- Wait, how do you get it?
You just like, is it like
a virus you pick up or?
- Yeah, I believe it's virus.
It's like an infection on your tonsil.
- [Joey] Oh, okay.
- It might be viral or bacterial.
- Kissing someone with it
or something, I don't know.
- Sucking too many dicks, right?
(laughing)
(indistinct)
- Now that I'm a Jojo
fan, I gotta be careful.
- Can't be going on any (indistinct).
- Don't wanna pick up tonsillitis
from my next blowjob.
- I don't know, generally I
just avoid going to the hospital
or clinic at all costs.
I'm like ...
- Yeah.
- I've said this before,
I just don't wanna go.
- Yeah.
- I'd rather, I'll be
like dead before I go.
Unless it's like, really severe.
And I'm in like a lot of pain.
- [Joey] Right.
- So, we kind of went on
like a one hour tangent
from Joey saying we're
gonna get back to explaining
the title of this video.
(laughing)
- Holy shit, I completely
forgot about that!
- In true Trash Taste -
- Trash Taste classic.
- Fashion.
Joey's like, "We'll get back to this."
- We'll get back to this.
And they never did!
- One hour later.
(laughing)
- Yeah, so, we're gonna be
leaving Japan after this episode
for a little bit of time.
Specifically two months.
Quote unquote.
- Is it two months?
- Month and a half?
- Month and a-
- Something like that.
- It doesn't really matter because I mean,
you guys aren't gonna
know the exact dates,
but we're gonna be filming
Trash Taste abroad.
- Yeah, we're going-
- [Joey] All sorts of places.
- Yeah, we're going,
the next arc is gonna be
Trash Taste abroad, basically.
And we're gonna say goodbye
to this studio for now.
Because we're gonna be filming in
some of the different countries
that we're gonna be in.
- I mean obviously one we can say,
because we announced it, like,
a couple of episodes
ago, but like you know,
if you guys watched the episode
four episodes ago, I think,
where we announced we were going to AX.
By the way, see you guys there.
Then obviously you'll know we're
gonna be in LA for a while.
- Yup!
- Yeah.
- So yeah, we're filming
some episodes in LA.
- And some in London as well.
- Yeah, we're gonna be,
because these boys are gonna be coming to
the wedding as well, my wedding.
Which, by the time of
release of this episode
should have just-
- It should have happened.
- Should have already happened!
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- So congrats.
- Yeah!
- Garnt!
(laughing)
Congrats, I guess!
- Thank you.
- If everything goes well.
- Garnt is married if
you're watching this.
- Garnt's married if you're watching this.
- This is, yeah, I'll be a married man IRL
by the time this episode comes out.
- IRL as opposed to virtually.
- Massive W.
- As opposed to YouTube Garnt, you know?
- Garnt's gonna be at the
alter and the guy's like,
"Do you say I do?"
Garnt's like, "Wait, what, why?"
(laughing)
I was fidgeting, bro. What's happening?
- So put the fidget spinner down!
- [Connor] Come on!
- But yeah like, so we're gonna be filming
some episodes in London, some in LA.
And we're gonna have
like, a lot more guests on
than we usually would for Trash Taste.
- Yeah, there's gonna be
like a lot of guests on.
- It's gonna be like an (indistinct).
- So we had like, no guests
for like 20 episodes.
And then we're gonna have
a lot of guests in a row.
And like obviously, you know,
some people are gonna like that.
Some people don't like it.
But I think we just wanna,
we wanna go somewhere and mix it up
and try something.
- Yeah!
- And you know, if you
don't like the episodes,
or you don't like, we'll be back!
You know, nothing's gonna change.
- Don't worry, we have over
100 episodes at this point.
- Yeah, you know, Trash
Taste isn't going anywhere.
So, you know,
it's something we wanna do,
we wanna mix it up,
and we hope that the change of scenery
will look interesting as well.
I mean it obviously won't
maybe not look as professional,
but hopefully it'll still
be the same old podcast.
- Nice breath of fresh air.
- Yeah. Because like,
we've had so many guests
that we've wanted to come on
and it's been like two years of just
constantly waiting and waiting, it's like,
maybe it's gonna come, maybe?
And then now that we can fly out,
maybe, like, we are just basically,
it's the floodgates just opening, right?
And it's just, everyone coming on at once
because it's everyone that
we've wanted to come on
and we've talked to before
about wanting to come on,
all coming on at once!
So ... we're excited.
And it's going to be a lot of fun, I hope.
- Yeah.
- I think so!
- It'll be a lot of big
episodes back to back, I think.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah.
- And we're not just going
to be filming guest episodes.
We're gonna be filming
some specials as well.
You're gonna have your like,
your first Trash Taste
specials abroad as well.
We're not gonna spoil
what those specials are.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But, yeah, we have-
- Should be good.
Should be good.
- Yeah yeah yeah. We have a
lot planned for Trash Taste.
In the coming months.
- And if you miss just us,
I'm sure there'll be some
episodes sprinkled in there
that are just the three of us.
- Oh yeah yeah.
- Definitely.
- Yeah.
- I know there's a good, a vocal bunch,
on the subreddit that love
the just us three episodes.
And I guess they're so used to it now, so.
- Yeah.
- It's such like an interesting
divide though, right?
Because it's like, you know,
in my head it was like,
yeah, the fucking guest
episodes are like, awesome,
because it's like a new
person, new perspective,
you know, whatever, new
topics to talk about right?
But then there are a lot of
people who are just like,
"Who?"
Like, you know like,
they look at the four of us,
it's like, "Who dis? Who dis man?"
- I get it.
I think we try to make the guest episodes
so even if you don't know the guest
you can kinda, they can come on, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean we've had, what,
three guest episodes
before this one, right?
- Also, you know, our guest episodes
aren't as personal, so I
understand that people might not
enjoy them as much, if
that's what they like most
about Trash Taste.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Because obviously we can't go into
a lot about how we feel about things
and our own life, 'cause it's like,
all right, we're tryna
make sure the vibe is good
and that the guest can vibe.
- Yeah, yeah. Exactly.
- Well that's why we
decided to just have it
the three of us when we started, right?
Because we were like,
if we put a fourth person in there,
not a whole lot of like,
deep conversation's
gonna happen, you know?
It was gonna be like too,
it's gonna be too on the surface.
- I mean we're clowns,
but sometimes we wanna not be clowns
and just wanna chill and vibe, you know?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Just vibing, bro!
- Just vibing!
- True, true.
- We're clowns but we also
vibe as clowns as well.
- It's a clown vibe.
(laughing)
- So I'm sure they'll
be fun America stories
while we're there.
- Oh yeah.
- And I'm sure I'll gain a lot of weight.
- A lot of fun UK stories
as well. I'm sure.
- God, I'm not looking
forward to gaining weight.
- Yeah, I'm trying,
I've been trying my fucking hardest
to not gain weight before like,
obviously my wedding as well, but like,
it's really hard whenever you travel out
because one of the hardest things
is keeping to a schedule, right?
Or keeping to habits.
And like, when you're
living in the same place,
and you like, build this habit,
you know, you can stay on this habit
and it's so much easier,
but when there's like,
even like a slight change
in environment or something,
you know, it's so easy for just like
one domino to fall over,
and like everything just falls over.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And you just like, slip into like,
the complete opposite
lifestyle of what you had.
- I'm trying my best to
stay healthy right now.
I've been like going to
the gym like every day.
- Yeah.
- Just like, working out,
'cause I'm like, I need it.
I need to be healthy
before we go out there.
- Couldn't be me.
(laughing)
- I don't know, I also wanna
get in shape as well, so.
I mean I feel more energized
when I've worked out.
So I feel like I need that.
- I go on like the exercise bike
every now and then still,
at home, 'cause we bought one,
quite a while ago, so like,
whenever I have time, I do that,
but like, I don't know,
again, like,
I was going to the gym for a while,
and then just that one trip out
for like a week, just
completely throws everything
out the window, you know?
And then you come back and you're like,
well fuck, now I gotta start
from the scratch again!
You know?
And you're just like,
not motivated at all.
And that's just like,
it's just a complete,
like, habit killer.
- Also depends on like, I don't know,
I'm kinda picky.
Like if that, 'cause some hotels are like,
we have a gym.
And then you rock up to this gym,
and it is literally like
a treadmill from the 80s,
that like, it is just so shit.
And you're like, well okay,
I mean I guess I'll do that,
and they got like no weights or anything,
and you're like, okay,
I mean, all right, I guess I'll just run.
And then you're just like, okay,
and then you go to the next place
and they're like, "We have a gym."
Oh, gym's closed or something.
Like it's just like, it's so hard to like,
stay consistent working out
when you're traveling and stuff.
It's impossible.
- I don't even try to pretend to
try and keep up with the habits.
- I remember when I was
going to the gym crazy,
like when I lost the
majority of my weight,
like before I came to Japan.
I was doing it whilst
going to the conventions,
and it was so fucking hard.
Fucking waking up in the
morning before a convention
and going to the gym.
- To the gym? Oh my god.
- It was so hard.
Oh my god, and also bringing
your gym gear with you?
It's a pain in the ass.
- Just bring your 75% dumbbells, man!
That's all you need, right?
That's all you need!
- You don't realize, right?
In your suitcase, shoes
take up a lot of room!
- Oh, yeah yeah yeah!
- Weirdly! Shoes are a pain in the ass.
And then also, shoes get dirty.
So you're like, I wanna kinda like,
cover them up.
- Yeah.
- It's just like a pain in the ass.
And then you gotta bring gym clothes,
which you're not gonna
wear any other time.
- Okay.
- Any other time!
- Like, I remember before,
when I used to travel, I'd be like,
I'd have to use like,
the weight limit to its
fucking maximum, right?
- [Joey] Oh, of course.
- Like you'd have to
pack as much as you can
and if you don't,
then you could squeeze in more there,
but now I'm like,
I wanna pack as light as possible, right?
And like, shoes are the most like,
annoying things, right?
- So annoying.
- Because they're like-
- Because they're light,
but they take up the most space.
- Well the thing is, are they light?
Sometimes shoes aren't light!
- I mean, if you're packing like, boots,
like if you're packing
like fucking Doc Martens
then it's like, I need like,
separate luggage just for
these fucking Doc Martens.
But like ...
- Because like, here's the thing.
Like, do you normally pack
extra pairs of shoes with you?
- I only pack the everyday
shoes and the nice shoes.
- It depends where I'm going.
Sometimes, like,
if I'm going to like,
say like a completely different,
like if I'm going somewhere that's like,
really summery and beachy,
then like, you know,
I'll take like, a couple
of like flip flops.
- Oh, flip flops don't count!
They aren't shoes.
- But like, you know,
if I'm going somewhere
and I know I need to go to like,
a fancy dinner or
something, then you know,
I'll bring some like, dress
shoes and shit like that.
- Yeah yeah yeah, and they
are just like the most
fiddliest things to try and
fucking fit in your luggage.
- But if I just need
like, a pair of sneakers,
then I'm just taking the
one pair of sneakers.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- You know?
- Like how many jeans do you bring?
How many pairs of trousers do you bring?
- Oh, one pair of trousers.
- Yeah 'cause-
- Yeah, one pair of jeans.
- 'Cause I'm just like, for some reason,
it's so weird, I like
bring like 10 T-shirts,
five hoodies or whatever,
and I'm like, do I need
an extra pair of jeans?
Sometimes the answer's no, you know?
- I saw this YouTube Shorts,
it was people going around asking people
how much underwear they brought
for like a five day trip.
- Right.
- And I was just like, I was shocked.
- Is it not five?
- Yeah! Well how much would
you bring to a five-day trip?
How many pairs of underwear?
- Okay, like ...
Like, it's five minimum,
but sometimes I'm like,
maybe I need that extra pair of underwear.
- Maybe I'll shit myself?
- Maybe I'll shit myself!
- Maybe I'll shit my-
It's not underwear. It's socks.
How many pairs of socks do you bring?
- Oh, I always bring extra socks.
- Wait, why?
- Because, you know,
you might run into an instance where like,
say wherever you are is
rainy, for instance, right?
Your socks get wet.
You don't wanna wear those wet socks
for the rest of the day.
- Okay, but see, I'm
talking about underwear.
Socks I can kind of ...
- Okay, underwear for me,
if it's a five day trip,
I'm bringing max six.
- How much are you guys bringing?
What are you guys bringing?
- [Man] Max six.
- For a five day trip.
- Six?
- [Man] Max six.
- Six, right? Six?
- [Man] Socks?
- Underwear.
How many pairs of underwear
for a five day trip?
- Six.
- Yeah, six.
- Like, for me, the amount of socks
and the amount of underwear
you bring should be equal.
Right?
- Yes.
- Yes?
- Yeah.
- Joey you were, your face was just like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah."
- On this video, people were like,
eight, nine, 10, 11.
And then like, three.
(laughing)
- Yeah, it was as if I had like, one.
- It was like, whoa.
But like, eight?
What is happening?
Are you bringing eight pairs of under-
What has happened on your trips?
- You gotta like, double up, right?
- Like, I'm sorry.
When you're working out, it's
a different story, right?
'Cause if you're planning
to work out, I get it,
because when I work out-
- You're gonna sweat in 'em.
- I'm running through socks and underwear.
- Yeah, of course! Of course!
- I'm not re-wearing that underwear.
- Yeah, of course.
- It sucks, 'cause you're like,
fuck, I only got half a
day out of this underwear.
I need to fucking wash it.
Kinda sucks.
But like, if you're just going on a trip,
why do you need more than five pairs?
It doesn't make any sense to me.
- It also depends on the climate.
'Cause if you're going to like,
especially like a southeast Asian country,
you are sweating through
that fucking underwear, man.
Like-
- Okay, that's-
- You're taking like four showers a day.
- Yeah yeah yeah!
The swamp ass, man,
it's just like, it's on another level.
You need those extra
pairs of underwear, man!
- But like, this was like in America.
Like, I don't think there's
a single place in America
where you need more than
five pairs of underwear.
- Aw, I guess, unless
you're going on like a
five day trip to like, Death Valley.
- Maybe, like, I just think that like,
you know, whatever.
And I've been trying to like, you know,
like I said, I'm trying to minimize.
But also, did you ever
try and do anything sneaky
with your suitcase at the airport?
Did you ever try to like,
get past the weight limit?
- How so?
- One time ... I can't remember
which airport it was in.
The thing where the suitcase was.
There was no other staff to this side.
There was just the person
there behind the desk.
And I had the suitcase just like,
the suitcase I had was kinda like,
the wheels were kinda, like not centered.
Not on the edge, but like,
kind of going towards the center.
So the edge was leaning off.
And so I just do that
thing where you just like,
put your foot, and just like,
slightly lift it up,
to like, get a kilogram or two off.
And then just hold it,
like some kind of Nen user, you know?
You gotta have the conversation while just
slightly holding it.
'Cause it was gonna go over.
I knew it was over
because on the way there it was over.
So on the way back, I was like ...
- How much was it over?
- Like five kilograms.
- Okay, fuck. You're not
getting away with that.
- So I, no I did!
- Huh?
- I got it down to like,
it was 20 kg limit, right?
It was going to like 24, 25.
- 20 kg limit?
Who are you flying with?
- Most of the airlines have
20 kg on one bag, limit.
- Is it not 23?
- Normally 20. Actually,
it depends on the airline.
- [Man] A lot of them are 20.
- Yeah, sometimes 15 as well.
So I was like,
I need to shave five off
this bag (indistinct).
And it was so-
- Warm up the calf.
- Dude, it was so hard!
'Cause I'm like, on the desk like this,
trying to get my documents.
And I'm like ...
My foot is like steel right now.
I'm like, lifting it up.
But you gotta keep it even!
'Cause if it's wobbling,
they know what you're doing.
- Yeah yeah.
- But like, I figure,
what are they gonna do?
They're not gonna kick me off the plane
if they find out I'm-
- It just reminds me of like, you know,
in Giorgio where they put the chocolate
under the water, and just like,
change the level of it.
While you're just having a conversation.
I've been fucking with
you this entire time!
- I knew, 'cause I had to
pay the fee on the way there!
'Cause I didn't have any
other way of taking it.
They charged me like, $70 or something.
To bring on this bag.
The flight was like 300!
And I was broke!
I couldn't afford 70, so I was like,
"I'm gonna do this, bro."
So it was like a Jojo, like,
fight thing, where I was like,
holding it up with my like,
left foot on the desk,
doing my passport, getting the ticket.
- He was like, Nani!
- Put it on, and when I put it on,
I just kept talking to her,
so it seemed like nothing was ...
And I wasn't that close to it either!
Because the desk was really tall.
And there was no one else.
- So you can't see.
- No one could see me doing it,
and there was no one behind me,
and I was scared that
someone would call me out,
but no one did, so yeah.
It all worked nicely.
- No, if there was someone behind you
they would have just been like, "Damn."
- Yeah, if somebody called me out,
I'd have been like,
"What is wrong with you?
Let me, you wanna be
fucked over by them too?
Come on!"
But one time, I will say,
when I was moving to Japan,
and I had like, three suitcases,
the woman was like,
my suitcases were like, way over.
'Cause I had like, my
computer gear and stuff.
So it was like, 10, 15 kg over.
And she just like, looked at me,
and I was like, I must
have looked really sad,
'cause I was like, I'm moving!
And she was like ...
(sighs) All right, I won't tell anyone.
And then she just let it off for free.
- Aww, that's-
- I love it when they do that sometimes!
- Yeah, because like,
it's so hard, so because like,
here's the thing, like,
I've had to like do similar things,
but I try to prepare as much as possible
before going in.
So you weigh it and then you're just like,
how much can you like,
physically bring on a carry on?
Okay?
Like you push that to the limit,
because you have the carry on,
and then sometimes you can have like,
a bag, which is not too big,
or doesn't look too big.
- Yeah, it's not allowed to be big. Yeah.
- But like, you push the limits about
how much you can have on a carry on
and a personal item?
Is that what it's called, right?
- Yeah, a personal item.
- So you have to spread
things as equally as possible.
And I noticed like, the
magic number is between like,
.5 and one kilograms, right?
If it's between, if it's over,
by like less than like, one kilogram,
or just like ...
Like, I've met airlines that it's like,
if it's exactly one kilogram,
they will charge you.
But if it's like, 0.9,
they're just like ...
We'll let it go. We'll let it go.
The 0.1 kilograms makes a big difference.
- That just reminded me of like,
the time when I got stranded in Canada,
the one time, because I lost my passport.
So, I don't know if I've told
this story on Trash Taste.
But like, this is like
five, six years ago.
I went to a con in Montreal.
And you know, I was like,
hanging out with a bunch
of mates or whatever.
And then I was flying back to Australia,
but I had to stop by in Toronto first.
So it was like, Montreal to Toronto,
and then Toronto back to Sydney.
- [Garnt] Right.
- So then, I got to Montreal Airport,
and I was like, "I can't
find my fucking passport."
And you know, this is the first time ever
I've lost my passport,
let alone overseas, right?
Which is fucking terrifying.
I find out later that my
friend who was with me
at the con the entire time,
I had accidentally put
my passport in his bag,
and he had already flown home
back to like, I think he lives in like,
San Jose or something.
So he was already in America,
with my passport in his bag.
And so, I got to Montreal airport-
- That's like, nightmare.
- [Joey] It was. It was a
fucking nightmare, right?
- I think I'd cry.
- Yeah. No, and like,
I got to Montreal airport,
I told them the situation, they were like,
"All right, what you can do is that,
there's an Australian
embassy in Toronto anyway.
So just, we'll let you
fly to Toronto at least,
but then you're gonna
have to find a hotel,
go to the embassy, get a new passport."
- Right.
- Right?
So, you know, I'm fucking
freaking out, right?
So I fly to Toronto.
I put in a hotel.
And then my friend who
had the passport was like,
"I can try and like, email,"
not email, but like ...
(laughing)
"I can try and send this to you.
Like, mail it to you," right?
Through like, FedEx or whatever.
But like, I don't know how
long it's gonna take, right?
Not to mention, it's technically
in a different country.
So it has to go through
like, customs and shit.
Right?
I stayed in that hotel
for five days straight.
- Oh my god.
- Every day.
- FedEx? Took five days?
- Five days.
- Bruh. Bruh.
- Did he like, cheap out?
- No no no no no no!
It was stuck in customs for
like, three and a half days.
- Bro!
- So it got to Canada, like
on the morning of day two.
But because it's just a passport,
it was literally just
stuck in customs for like,
three whole days.
- What the fuck were they doing?
- I don't know, checking it
was legitimate or something?
Like, no illegal activities or whatever?
But like, I, dude like,
I was so fucking depressed.
'Cause like, I'm stuck in this hotel,
in the middle of Toronto.
I don't know anyone
who lives there, right?
I wake up in the morning,
and I'm literally sitting in
front of the reception phone
just hoping that I get a call being like,
"You've got a package."
Right?
- I hope you had an ergonomic keyboard.
- No, I didn't.
- Fuck, man.
- I was like, if I only had my 75%.
- Damn, dude!
- You were training up for COVID, man!
Like-
- Yeah, I know.
So like, so the first
thing I had to do though,
was I had to go to Toronto airport
to like, change my flight, right?
To be like, "Hey, I've lost my passport.
I don't know what to do."
And it was like this like
Canadian woman who was there.
And she was like, "Okay, um, you know,
because it's an unfortunate situation,
we can change your flight for free,
if you fly tomorrow."
And you know, I didn't
know when this package
was gonna arrive, right?
So I was just like, "Okay
yeah, sure, let's do that."
You know.
Just so I don't get my
flight completely canceled.
Of course, next day happens.
It doesn't arrive.
- [Connor] Oh shit.
- So then the next day I had
to go back to Toronto airport,
and the same woman was there.
And she was like, "Okay. If
you wanna change it to like,
two or three days later,
which is the next available flight,
it's gonna cost you like, you know,
a couple of thousand dollars."
- [Connor] Jesus.
- Right?
And at the time, you know,
because I'd only just
started doing YouTube.
I didn't have that kinda money.
I was still living off
fucking scraps, right?
For YouTube Ad rev.
And so I was like, and you know,
I was like, on the verge of tears,
being like-
- I would be too!
- I was like-
- On the verge? I'd be
crying already! Like-
- I was on the verge of
tears and just being like,
and I was just like,
"I don't have that kind
of money right now."
And I was like, what do I do?
Should I call my mum?
But it's like, three in the morning
in Australia right now.
Blah blah blah blah blah.
And then the woman just like, kinda like,
was just looking at me
panicking for a little bit.
And then she just starts
typing away on a keyboard.
And then she prints out this ticket.
For two days to go.
And she hands it to me,
and then she just, I'll never forget it,
she just says, "I'd better
not see you here ever again."
(chuckling)
- Oh my god!
- And she just gave me this free ticket.
Dude, I fucking cried.
I just like, I like,
I got on my knees and I
just broke down crying.
Because this lady just
literally just gave me this
$2000 plane ticket.
Just, because she felt sorry for me?
And I'm like, that would
never happen in Japan.
In Japan it's like, "Hold on,
I gotta call up the manager,"
and then the manager's manager.
- Oh no. In Japan they'd be like, sorry.
- They would never let it happen.
So like, luckily,
two days later, I got the fucking,
you know, passport, and I got the package.
And I fucking ripped that
shit open in the hotel room,
saw my passport, broke down crying again,
because I'm like, finally I can go home!
And then, yeah.
I got to Toronto airport
and I got my flight back.
And I was like, whoever you were, lady,
I will never fucking forget you.
That was like, that was the
moment where I was like,
you know what?
People are awesome.
There is a god!
- I can confirm that that
would never happen in Japan,
because I didn't have that
much of a stressful situation,
but something kinda similar
happened to me recently.
So, recently we went on a trip together.
And after the trip, I was
meant to fly to America.
Fly to America to meet Sydney's family.
Because I haven't seen
them since before COVID,
so I wanted to see them
once before I get married,
and become one big happy family.
So I had the tickets booked,
and because the schedule was so tight,
I had pre-packed all of my travel stuff
before going on the trip
with the boys, basically.
Sydney flew out, I believe
like, a week before me.
So she had flown off already, right?
And I remember, I packed
everything before.
And I put my passport in my travel bag.
Right?
And I remember coming home,
and I remember being absolutely knackered
from coming back from this boys' trip.
And then I was just like,
checking everything was ready to go,
ready to fly in like a day or two.
And then I notice the bag is missing.
- Oh no.
- Oh shit!
- And then I start panicking,
'cause I know the most like,
if there's one document I need,
it's my passport!
- Yeah, of course.
- Right? Especially because
I'm getting married in two months.
I can't be losing my fucking passport.
I need to fly back to the UK.
So I like start fucking
searching around the house
and everything, and I'm just like,
"She better not have.
She better not have."
And I phone her, I phone her,
and she's asleep, and it's 2 a.m. right?
- Wake the fuck up!
- I give her like 10 phone
calls, she's not picking up.
Phone her mum, she's not picking up.
Luckily her dad was still awake.
Luckily, I'm just like,
"Russel, I need you to
do me a massive favor.
Can you wake Sydney up now?
Can you wake Sydney up, right now!
Right now!"
And so, yeah.
He rushes over, he wakes Sydney up,
and I'm like, "Sydney,
do you have the bag?
Do you have the bag, Sydney?"
And she was like, (mumbles incoherently)
What?
I was like, "Sydney!
Sydney, this is not the time
to be asleep! You need to wake up now,
and you need to check
that you have the fucking
Aska travel bag, okay? Do you have it?"
And she's just like, "Um,
yeah. Yeah I have it."
I'm like, "Is my passport in there?"
And she's like, "Oh fuck."
(laughing)
Oh fuck!
And so, like she, like ...
I'm like, I don't know why she had
never used this bag before, like,
this is the one time
she decided to use this
as a travel bag.
But unfortunately she
didn't check the contents
of the bag, so ...
- Who doesn't check a bag?
Was there like, nothing else in this bag?
Was it just the passport in the bag?
- It was my passport and my other like,
vaccine travel documents that I needed.
- So basically all, everything you needed.
- So, yeah.
So everything I needed
to travel out of Japan.
- What the actual fuck?
- So it was like, empty.
It started from like the front pocket
which had like, literally like,
the one, everything I needed.
- Your life.
- Yeah, my life. My life.
- Your proof for existence.
- Yeah, my proof of
existence to Japan, right?
And so we're like trying to like,
plan this out to be like,
can I make this flight if we like,
do a frame perfect like,
frame perfect drop of this to like,
fucking DHL, right?
And we're like, "What's the closest DHL?"
Okay, so it's this place.
We can go home, you can wake
up tomorrow and go get it.
And then, I've realized unfortunately,
it's America, and they
don't work on the weekends.
- Yeah. Oh fuck!
- So I'm like, oh fuck!
I have to wait two days
before they can even
put the drop-off.
Even if DHL are like, super on point,
which they were, actually.
DHL were like, very fast about it.
I'm still not gonna get it in time.
So, I have to like,
if I wanna go to America-
- Change the strat!
- Yeah, I have to like, delay.
I have to like, change the flights, right?
So that was stressful enough,
not having my passport on me, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So I remember phoning up ANA.
To be like, look.
I'm in this situation now.
Like, I don't know if I
qualify for a change of flight.
Because the thing is, like,
I believe I bought a
flexible ticket, right?
- [Joey] Right.
- So I wasn't, I didn't buy one on like,
I didn't buy a ticket, on
like some random fucking site.
- You bought it from ANA.
- I bought it from ANA itself, right?
And so I thought, paying like,
a bit of a premium price,
as opposed to buying from like,
fucking Skyscanner or whatever,
that I, you know,
that there was a little bit
of wiggle room on that, right?
'Cause it wasn't a cheap ticket.
And like, I don't know why
flying to America right now
is so fucking expensive,
from like everywhere.
'Cause it was like, the cheapest
economy ticket they had,
and it was still like, fucking like,
almost like a grand, or like two grand.
I can't fucking remember.
- Jesus.
- Jeez.
- One way?
- Yeah, one way!
- Fucking hell!
- Yeah yeah yeah, it was like ...
- Aren't one way flights
though, weirdly expensive?
- Return flights are like, weirdly more,
like less expensive.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- I think it's something to
do with how long you're gone
and there's different
price points based on
if you're flying with the same carrier
and how far apart you're flying.
- Something like that.
- There's some really strange
rules with ticket pricing.
- Yeah, so I phone up ANA,
and I'm like, look,
here's the situation.
Can I change my flight?
Can I change my flight to, you know,
a few days after?
Or whatever's convenient.
And they're like, "Yes,
there's a flight on X day,
that's still available,
I've still got seats."
And I'm like, great!
Can I change to that flight?
How much would it cost?
Would it cost anything?
And I remember her like, hearing like the,
the keyboard tapping.
- That's never good.
- And then she pauses.
And she pauses, and she's just like,
"Um, hold on, can I,
I need to go see the manager quickly."
- Oh my god.
- And I'm like, that's not-
- That's not a good sign.
- That's not a good fucking sign.
- Everything in Japan.
If anything needs the manager.
- Yeah yeah yeah. 'Cause I'm like, oh man,
how many hundreds of dollars
am I gonna have to like
fucking pay to like change my flights?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And then like, I wait
for like five minutes,
I'm like, okay, I can afford
like a few hundred dollars
luckily enough.
'Cause I really wanna go see the family.
And then she comes back.
And then she's like,
"Okay. I have just
confirmed with my manager.
If you would like to
change your plane ticket
to this date, it is $4000."
- What?
- And I was like ...
Can you repeat that?
- Could you repeat that?
Could you repeat that?
- That doesn't make any fucking sense!
- 'Cause they said it in yen, right?
'Cause they said it in
yen, I was just like ...
- 400,000 yen.
- Yeah, so I was like,
"My Japanese must be rusty,
'cause I think I must have misheard."
- There must have been some static!
- Yeah! 'Cause I think like,
is that what it is in Japanese?
I must have added an
extra zero in my head,
because that is not 400,000 yen.
I must have heard 40,000 yen.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And just misheard.
So I was like, "Could
you repeat that please?"
And then they repeated
that, and I was just like,
"So, to confirm, in English,
that is 400,000 yen, right?"
'Cause I was like, I'm like,
my (indistinct) is not
(indistinct) enough.
I'm (indistinct) right now.
My (indistinct) is definitely not
(indistinct) enough right now.
I'm mishearing this, right?
- Oh my god!
- And then she was like, yes,
it is 400,000 yen.
And I was just like ...
how is this possible?
And she was like, "I apologize.
Because there's a small change fee
and the tax is different."
Like, I couldn't understand.
Like, no matter what she says,
there is no justification
for an increase from like-
- Yes, you got a flex ticket
and somehow it ended up costing
more than the original ticket.
- Yeah, like you're not,
you didn't like, upgrade to
business class or anything,
right, like that's the kind
of price we're talking about.
- This was economy.
And I was just like, "Is that 4000 yen
on top of the two?"
Like, is that-
- [Joey] On top of the thousand.
- Is that like, 4000 on top of the ticket
that I just already paid for?
And she was like, yes.
- Wow.
- So-
- So it's a $5000 one-way
ticket to America.
- Yeah yeah!
And so like, I'm like,
"There is no fucking
way this makes sense."
So I go on fucking Skyscanner.
Like, as we're on the call,
and I'm just like,
"I can see, I can buy a
ticket on your website
for $2000. Like, a new ticket for $2000.
How does it make sense
that you're charging me
$4000 to change my ticket?
To change it? Change it, right?"
And she was like, "I apologize, sir,
that's just how the system works.
It's the upcharge for
changing the ticket."
- No, that's a scam, bro.
- And I'm just like, okay.
So, it's cheaper for
me to buy a new ticket
even if it's like double
the price at this point
from what I originally paid.
Can I get a refund for the original
ticket I paid?
- It's gonna cost you $1000.
- For the original ticket I paid.
In order to get the refund back
so I can buy a new ticket.
And she was like, "Oh yes.
The cancellation fee will be $900."
(laughing)
- How? How?
What's the justification?
- How does that work?
- Didn't you buy a flexible ticket?
Isn't the whole point of these that they-
- Flexible tickets
means you can change it.
You can't refund it.
- Some of them let you.
- Some of them do!
- You can change it!
- Some of them do, and I was just like,
"Am I talking to the circus right now?"
Like, I didn't say that,
but that's what I wanted to say.
- You are not the clown!
You are the whole circus right now.
- Am I applying for clown (indistinct)?
What's going on?
Oh my god, dude.
- So my choices are either to
pay $4000 to change my ticket,
or to like, get $900,
to pay $900 to cancel a ticket-
- To buy a $2000 ticket.
- To buy a new $2000 ticket.
And I'm just like, I am not doing this!
I'm like, after like,
so, for the first time in my life,
I was like, "Can I speak to the manager?"
Like, I, 'cause the thing is,
I am not the type of guy
who goes Karen mode, okay?
- [Joey] Of course, of course.
- I am not the type of guy.
But they were taking the piss!
- I mean, I think anyone in that situation
would go Karen mode, 'cause
that's fucking ridiculous.
Like ...
- So I ask for the manager, and like,
it was, the reasoning for
like the upcharge of that much
is because I wanted
the flight within like,
if I had waited I believe like,
I believe like eight
days, eight or nine days,
then it would be a lot cheaper,
but because there was this like, window,
where I wanted to change the flight to,
even though there were flights available,
and the flight ticket
was cheaper to buy new,
changing to that,
changing to within that date range
meant that they had to
upcharge the ticket.
- Right.
- And there was nothing that-
- Which still doesn't make sense.
- Yes, which still doesn't make sense,
so there was nothing I could do about it.
I talked to the manager, I was like,
"Look, is there anything
you can do at all,
because like, I'm not lying,
but this is ridiculous."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You are not giving me any way out-
- I'd be pissed off.
- You are not giving me a solution.
My solution is, I pay $900 to pay $2000.
Like ...
- That is so dumb.
- Like like like, you are not-
- That's literally like
the enter the lottery
to buy the ticket, you know?
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Oh my god!
- So, unfortunately, I
didn't get a solution.
I lost $900 to cancel my ticket,
and I flew to England for
a fraction of the price
for this headache to go to America.
- Christ.
- So yeah, unfortunately-
- I don't know what's going
on with flights to America.
It's insane right now.
I was trying to get flights from the UK.
- [Joey] Inflation, dude.
- Yeah, flights from the
UK to America as well,
it's crazy expensive!
- Really?
- I was like, what the fuck? Yeah.
Meanwhile, flights from
Tokyo to London were like,
it was like $1000 with business!
I was like, what the fuck is going on?
What is happening?
- No one's wanting to
go to the UK right now.
- Well, I think no one's wanting
to go from Tokyo as well.
- Oh, that's true, yeah.
- Yeah. So okay, I got,
because I gotta ask now.
Just remind me, have you
guys ever gone full Karen?
Have you guys ever needed to like,
ask for the manager?
- [Connor] I don't think so!
- [Garnt] Joey, don't answer that!
(laughing)
- I could legitimately say no,
but of course the entire fucking
audience is gonna be like,
(indistinct).
But like, legitimately, no I haven't.
'Cause, just like, I'm
not the kind of person
to like, go to a restaurant and be like,
"My soup is 20 minutes late."
I'm just like, I don't fucking care.
- I feel like I normally try to like,
when I'm talking in those situations,
I normally try to build up
some rapport with the person
I'm talking to.
- Yeah.
- Yeah!
- And they'll normally be like,
"Yo listen, you know,
nothing can be done."
And I'll be like, "I mean,
I'll take your word for it."
- Yeah, there's like, you know,
I feel there's like,
if there is a problem with
some kinda service or,
you know, situation,
there's only so much that
I know the manager can do anyway,
so I'm just like, just don't even bother.
I'll fold, I don't give a fuck.
Like, it's not a life or death situation.
- In that situation I'd be tempted to,
but even then I'm like,
I'm so lazy that I'm like,
all right, I guess ...
- I also don't wanna cause a scene.
You know, even though I'm
perfectly in the right
to cause a scene, because I'm
the one getting fucked over,
like, there's a part
of me that's just like,
no, I don't wanna like,
be the asshole, you know?
So it's like, yeah.
I don't know, I don't think I've ever ...
- I've never done it,
but I mean, I don't think like,
I don't know, it's weird,
'cause like, if you cause a scene,
sometimes you get what you want.
It sucks.
- Yeah, right?
- 'Cause it's like, I don't,
I'd just rather not.
- I've been in situations where-
- Wish you would just treat
me like a human being.
- Yeah. I've been in situations
where I've been in like
a restaurant or whatever,
and I've seen someone else cause a scene,
and they get what they want,
and I'm just like, what an asshole!
You know?
- 'Cause the thing is like,
it's, 'cause I hardly ever go full Karen,
but I've seen it work.
I just like, I could,
I don't have the ability
to do that myself.
'Cause I remember like, on
this trip back to England,
there was this point where,
we were on a night out.
We were with all our friends, right?
And Sydney was tired,
and so like, I took her home,
took her home like, earlier.
Everyone else went on drinking.
And eventually they ended
up in a casino, right?
And so I was like,
cool, I'm not tired yet.
Is it cool if I go out to, you know,
continue with my mates
and continue drinking
and have fun?
And then I was like, yeah.
Sydney was already passed
out, so I was like, cool.
I'm just gonna go.
- Please make noise if you object.
(laughing)
- I don't hear anything!
(overlapping chatter)
- And so there was a sizable
group inside the casino.
So I get there, and I wanna go in,
and there's a bouncer at the door.
And he's just like, sorry.
You can't come in unless you're a member.
And I was just like, but,
I know you've let plenty
of other people in,
because my entire friend
group is in there.
And my entire friend group was in there,
and they weren't members,
so what's happening with that?
And then he was just like,
oh, you know,
he was like, sorry, no members right now.
No entry right now unless you're a member.
And I was just like,
I know, like,
I know he can let me in, you know?
It's not like a massive casino,
and the thing is, I
see people walking out.
I see like, plenty of people walking out.
And I like, you know when you can tell,
like, that there's a bouncer,
who just wants to go on a power trip.
- Oh yeah yeah yeah.
- [Garnt] Like, you know what I mean.
You know what I mean.
- Of course, of course.
- I like, I knew it wasn't like,
it wasn't like the busiest
place in London or whatever.
It was a place that I
knew the bouncer was just
trying to be an asshole.
Because I could clearly see
there were people walking
in and out, right?
And there were people that were going out
and saying that they were leaving,
and so I was just like, okay,
what is the right angle to go for
to try and get myself in, right?
- 'Cause I guess you wanna
see your friends, right?
- Yeah, 'cause I'm like,
I really wanna see my friends,
because the night wasn't
even like that late.
- Was it like a Saturday or something?
Was it a Saturday or, like a Tuesday?
- I believe it was a Sunday.
- I could understand maybe
if it was a Saturday,
it was really busy, you know,
they'd maybe wanna limit it
to customers they know are gonna spend
a shit ton of money.
- But it wasn't even
like that busy, right?
- No, it wasn't even that busy.
- Yeah, so he's just being a dick.
(chuckling)
- Because, 'cause here's,
so 'cause like, so I'm like,
okay, I gotta at least
try to get in, right?
Because if I don't get in,
I didn't get to say
goodbye to all my friends
and like my night's over.
So I'm gonna at least like, try to get in.
And of course, I don't go full Karen.
I try to go for like-
- 75%.
(laughing)
- So I go for the friendly approach.
You know? Like ...
- You gotta start from
like the moment one, right?
- The rapport approach, right?
The rapport approach.
- The (indistinct) approach.
- Yeah, the (indistinct) approach!
- But there's nothing wrong with like,
being like, tryna explain,
like, just,
you know, maybe if there's not
like a giant line behind you.
Listen, I wanna see my friends,
they're all in there.
(chattering in agreement)
- Calmly explain the
situation, right? Yeah.
- I'd be like, look mate,
like I understand that you don't want like
a big group of like, strangers
coming in or whatever
at this time of the hour.
I get that, you know,
you're just like, you got some rules
that you need to follow
and everything like that.
Look, I'll be honest.
I'm just one guy.
I'm not local around here,
because I've literally flown in from Japan
just to hang out with my mates,
and I don't get this chance often.
And I was just like-
- The sympathy approach.
- 'Cause I was like, dude,
I'm not here to like, ruin your night.
I'm not here to like,
I will spend fucking money in there.
I know you just don't want
some fucking random dickhead
just like walking in and
everything like that.
I am not that random dickhead.
I'm not drunk.
I'm like a good-
- I'm a good boy!
- I'm a good boy, okay?
- I can attest.
Garnt is very well behaved.
Garnt is very very well behaved.
- Like, I was trying to be as
well fucking spoken as possible.
This was like me like,
putting on the tuxedo, like-
- [Joey] Speech 100.
- The Winnie the Pooh meme.
Speech 100, but like,
fucking hell, this guy
just was not having it.
He was like-
- Some bouncers are like that.
They're just like, they're not having it.
- 'Cause the thing is,
he would not even like,
have a conversation with me.
Like he was like, no.
- I can get it, 'cause they
probably deal with like
some really fucking awful asshole drunks.
- I get it, I get it. I get it.
- But at the same time it's like,
sometimes you're like, dude,
I'm not the problem here, dude!
- Yeah yeah.
- I'm not the one causing you problems!
I guess maybe I am by talking
to you too much, but ...
- Yeah yeah, exactly.
I was just like, look,
you know, and eventually,
I was just like ...
Fine, I guess,
you know, I guess my night's over.
And then one of my
friends comes out, right?
And she sees what's going on,
she's like, "What's going on here?"
And I was like, they have some rules,
and the bouncer's just like,
not communicating with me at all.
I don't think there's any way to get in.
And she's like, bet.
(laughing)
She's like, Karen mode activated.
There was like, an instant like,
an instant switch to be like,
"Um, excuse me? Like, do you know that
he's getting married in a month!"
- I thought she was gonna be like,
"Do you know who he is?
He's the anime zone!
The greatest YouTuber!"
- And she goes, and
she's able to just like,
go on this like, somehow-
- This guy probably
wants to get rid of her.
He's like, fuck this.
Fuck off.
- It's like this fucking
five minute rant, right?
It's like, you know,
when Senator Armstrong is
just like, standing there,
and (indistinct) is
just like fucking like,
pulling the punches, and he's just ...
- It's not budging.
- Yeah, he's not budging!
But like, after about five minutes,
he's just like, "Fine, you can go in."
I was just like, "That
worked? That worked?"
I thought being like
the nice guy would work!
But just like, fucking like,
going like, just like,
just going full Karen and just like,
calling for the manager
and just like, not letting up?
That works sometimes!
- But I think that's the thing, right?
It's like, I think the reason why
I don't go Karen mode, like, ever,
is because I've been on the
other side of that before.
Like when I used to work at like a bar.
And like, oh my god, I
still remember this dickhead
to this day, but like,
it was this absolute knobhead who, like,
he came in.
I was working, when I was working
up at the ski (indistinct)
I was working behind a bar, some nights.
And you know, I had to
pour like beers and shit
and whatever.
But then of course this fucking,
this dickhead walks in with
like, 10 of his mates, right?
And he was like, and he said,
"Oi, oi, can you come here for a second?"
And I was like, oh, you're talking to me?
All right, yeah, whatever.
That's a bit weird.
And then he's like, "Can
we get 20 B-52s please?"
And to explain what a B-52 is,
it's this liqueur shot
that's three layers, right?
And so the layering shit,
if you've ever made layering stuff,
you gotta like, slowly pour it,
at the back of a spoon,
otherwise it mixes, right?
So in other words, making one
of these takes a long time.
Because you wanna make
it look nice, right?
And this motherfucker was
like, 20 of them please.
And I was like, "Okay, sure."
I was the only one at the bar, right?
So I was like, all right,
I better start fucking
slaving away at it then.
But, you know, because it's,
you know, a restaurant, right?
And like a bar, I wanted
it to like, look nice.
I'm not just gonna
fucking pour it in, right?
I start pouring, you
know, a couple of them.
And then around like, the
third one that I'm making,
this dickhead just walks into the bar,
and he was like, "Oi, where
the fuck are the B-52s?"
He was like, "Get your manager!"
And I was like, "Motherfucker,
you wanna make it?
You wanna? Be my guest!
Be my guest, dickhead!
Make it right now!
You wanna make it any faster than me?
Do you want them or not?
You haven't even paid for it yet!
I don't even have to make 'em for you!"
And so of course, but you know,
that's what I said in my head, right?
But on the outside I was like,
"I'll get the manager right away."
(laughing)
So then the manager-
- I am the manager!
- So then I call the manager over,
and she's like this Japanese lady, right?
But like, you know,
who looks really nice on the outside,
but on the inside she's like,
a reverse Karen.
- Oh, 'cause she has to deal with like-
- 'Cause she has to deal with
dickheads like this, right?
So then she comes out and you know,
this nice like, you know,
short Japanese lady
comes out and she's like,
"Oh, what seems to be the problem?"
And you know, this guy
starts going off being like,
"Yeah, so he's fucking taking forever
making these drinks, you know,
like we've been waiting forever."
By forever they mean like,
you know, 10 minutes.
Right?
And, I've never seen someone go
reverse Karen on a customer before, right?
And she was just like, "Um, excuse me?
Do you wanna make these?
I don't think so!
So give him some fucking time!"
- I love videos of like
the employees of fast food places
just chewing out fucking-
- Yeah yeah, just being like,
and she was just like,
she literally was like,
"Get out."
- Good, yeah!
Fucking too right!
- Yeah, and you know,
he was, you know,
going off and being like,
"This is the worst place ever.
Fuck you guys."
She was like, I don't give a fuck.
Get out. Get the fuck out, right now.
And I was like, and you know,
because I was like,
fucking too shy and like,
scared to like say anything,
so in the back I was like, yeah!
Get 'em!
Yeah, get 'em! Get 'em!
(laughing)
So, I've been in that situation before.
So I think every time, you know,
I'm in a situation where, you know,
perhaps something is late or, you know,
where most people wouldn't
want to go Karen mode
in some situations.
I always remember that
situation, I'm like, no!
I don't wanna be that dickhead.
I'll wait.
- Well because like, part
of the reason that I was,
like, 'cause, I got like,
slightly annoyed at the bouncer,
wasn't because of the fact
that he wasn't letting me in.
But because like, he just refused to like,
engage with me.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- At all. Because like-
- He wouldn't explain it to you?
- Yeah, he just wouldn't explain it to me!
Because like, I could like,
I could tell he was just like,
he probably had a bad day or something.
I don't fucking know, but like,
he just wanted to exert
his power upon someone.
Like, I could feel that energy.
'Cause like, I've been to like,
places before where
you talk to the bouncer, and
they explain to you like,
look mate, it's (indistinct),
there's nothing I can do.
You know like, I would be like-
- Like they're like,
trying to help you, right?
- Yeah! And I'd be like, I get it.
Because I'm like, I'm a human as well.
But like, I was like,
he was like, nah.
Gotta prioritize our members.
And I was looking around.
I was like, thinking-
- Who?
- What fucking members?
- [Joey] Who?
- It's you and me.
I was like, there is no line here.
There is no line.
There's no line of people
waiting to come up.
I know for a fact,
because after I went in,
the casino was like 90% empty!
So I was just like, what?
I was just like, you know,
this is an asshole being an asshole,
and this is like, the only
thing that could beat an asshole
is a Karen.
And like, (laughing)
- Unstoppable force beats
an immovable object.
(laughing)
You know those YouTube videos
where they're like, yeah,
just like, bribe your way into everything,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah yeah yeah!
- Like, oh you want an
upgrade at a hotel room?
Just slip the person 50 bucks.
- Yeah.
- I've always thought
about stuff like that.
'Cause I'm like, I'd love to be able to
have the slickness and the coolness
to pull that shit off, but
I'm just thinking like,
how do I discreetly just
give you like, 10 pounds?
In a way that like, doesn't
make me look fucking stupid.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah.
- I was like, what if
you say no to me? Right?
And I'm like, "Aw, gimme a second."
Just pull out a 10 note.
Can I come in?
- Please?
- Like, can I come in now?
Like, surely I would have to preemptively
give him some money.
And at that point, what if no
one else paid money to get in,
and I'm the asshole
who gave him 10 pounds?
And alternatively, what if
you go to like that whole,
I see all those fucking TikToks of,
just give your hotel
check-in person 50 bucks!
Like, it's like, okay,
what if the hotel's just actually full?
Like, you actually just gave them $50
and you're a dickhead?
- I've seen that before though!
Where like, I saw a guy at like a club
or like a bar or something,
who like, you know,
did like the whole dickhead, being like,
pulls out a 20 and like,
puts it into the bouncer's, like, pocket.
And the bouncer looks at it and he's like,
"All right, gimme a second,
I'm gonna go talk to
the manager about it."
And he goes in, he
comes out and he's like,
"Sorry, we're full."
(laughing)
And then everyone in the
line just starts laughing
being like, what a dickhead!
- I've seen it work and not work.
I've seen like ...
- When it doesn't work, it's hilarious.
- But to me it's like, all right,
the benefits don't outweigh
the absolute humility
of getting rejected, trying
to offer money to someone
to get into something.
- Yeah, it's like you not only lost money,
but you also didn't get what you wanted.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah, exactly.
- There's some people who like have the,
I think they have the personality
that matches up to that kind of behavior.
- Oh yeah!
- I'm not slick at all.
I cannot do this stuff.
- I can't do that.
- And I've been with
guys who are just like,
"Let's come to a solution,"
and then they like,
fucking give the 10 bucks-
- Do you mean Jan?
- Yeah, I was like, just
say Jan. Just say Jan.
- I've not seen Jan do it,
but I bet Jan would do it.
- No, not unless like,
Jan has the energy that
he could pull it off.
- No, Jan has the energy
he can pull it off
without ever getting his wallet out.
- [Connor] Yeah but Jan would-
- He's just like, let's talk.
- Jan would do it, get rejected,
and then not care that he was rejected.
He'd just be like, okay,
we'll go somewhere else.
But to me it's like, that's
crushing embarrassing.
- Yeah, I can't do that.
- You know what? If you tell me it's full,
I don't have a magical Karen that appears
to sort it out for me.
- I don't have like, Karen's not my,
I don't have like a-
- I'm like a cool Karen.
- I don't have like a
stand I can pull out,
it's like, Karen!
(laughing)
- I don't have a Karen to
come out and help me, so,
I guess I'm done.
- Yeah 'cause like ...
- I'd just go for tryna
be a clown a little bit,
maybe they'll feel
like, oh that was funny.
I'll let this guy in.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
I try and like, humor my
way through things, right?
- 'Cause-
- It doesn't work.
- No, it doesn't work.
- 'Cause the thing about
those bribes that I've seen
is just like, how do you
know how much to give?
You know like, what's the
right amount to bribe someone
of like-
- Well, if you're tryna get into like,
you know, a Michelin star restaurant,
I don't know how that would work.
That doesn't make any sense.
But like a club, if it's a shit club,
maybe you just give
'em like, I don't know-
- [Joey] I've got six pence.
- And I want two drinks.
Maybe people who do this often know.
There's a system.
I don't know.
- There's like a tier list, right?
- Yeah, maybe they can
explain it to me how it works.
Based on like, how nice or
expensive the drinks are.
And I'm like, I've never heard of being
rejected from a casino though.
That's, only like drunk
people get rejected
from casinos normally.
Were you tipsy, Garnt?
- I was not tipsy.
- Like Garnt's telling the story
meanwhile he was like, two bottles deep.
- I mean-
- He was like Wolf of Wall Street,
like fucking crawling up to it.
- That's how I remember it at least!
I'm sure it came out as just like-
- Hello, my name is Garnt Maneetapho
and I would like to
enter this establishment.
And meanwhile, (groans incoherently).
(laughing)
- I just flew in from Japan!
- Well you said you had to
take Sydney home, right?
So odds are you probably,
even if you did drink,
you probably would have
fucking sobered out.
- Yeah.
- He had to take Sydney home, so.
(laughing)
- It was a good night.
We went to the casino.
It was a happy end to the story.
- That's good.
- And it was the one time in my life that
seeing someone go full Karen
was impressive, and it
actually worked as well.
- Damn. Not that I would
ever have the balls
to do it myself.
- No, I was just standing there,
and I was just, I was impressed.
- That's what everyone needs, though.
Like, you don't need to be a Karen.
You just need to know a Karen.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- That's all you need.
You just need that one
mate who will be there-
- Karens are bad, except
for when they work for me.
(laughing)
- Karens suck, unless you can tell them
to do something that you
want to get out of them.
- Okay, no no no.
Karens suck unless the
manager or the person
is being an equal asshole.
- [Joey] Exactly, yeah. Agree.
- Like you know, like normally
I don't advocate for this,
like, at all.
Because you know, service
people go through enough.
Service people go through-
- I see videos of people like,
arguing at McDonald's,
asking for free food.
I'm like, what happened at
birth that you became like this?
Like, how were you dropped hard enough
to go to a McDonald's and like,
berate a 14-year-old kid.
- You're just like, being
a brat about it, right?
Like they're probably a
brat their entire life.
- There are only very few points,
and some, and then like yeah,
if the service person is
being an asshole, yes.
You should be a Karen,
even though I still don't have it in me
even if they are being an asshole.
There have been plenty
of points where I'm like,
I should go full Karen, you know?
Because there have been
plenty of points where
they have been the assholes,
and I'm totally within my
rights to go full Karen,
but like, it's just,
it's just so hard man.
It's so hard.
- Luckily Google reviews exist, so.
- Yes.
- I mean you know, like
that fucker who ordered
the 20 B-52s, I would
have loved to have like,
snapped back at him.
But I just, I couldn't, man.
I couldn't.
I didn't have the balls.
- Or when they tell you
that you get charged
$4000 to change your ticket.
- [Joey] It's so stupid.
- Absolute, absolute (indistinct).
- So yeah, bottom line,
just don't be a Karen.
Just know a Karen.
(laughing)
- I activate my stan!
Karen!
- Okay, that's what you can do.
If the bouncer is like,
being a dickhead to you,
just be like, "Oh, you're approaching me?
Karen!"
(laughing)
- [Connor] Oh my god.
- Karens are just real stans.
- Standing here, I realize!
- Shut the fuck up.
Get an ergonomic keyboard
and you can get a Karen, I guess.
Then you can tell her when to shut up.
All right, thank you so much for watching
this episode of Trash Taste.
- But hey.
- Patreons.
- Look at these Patrons! Oh my god!
They're not Karens.
- They're not Karens.
- Yeah, because they support us.
- Unless they know the
exact point to be a Karen.
- Unless they have like a
Karen mode that activates.
But hey, if you'd like
to support the show,
then make sure to go over to our Patreon.
Patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter,
send us some memes on the subreddit,
and if you hate our face,
listen to us on Spotify, and yeah.
From next episode, we won't be here.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna be somewhere else.
Somewhere out there in the world.
- I mean, we'll still be here on YouTube!
- [Joey] We'll be on YouTube!
- You will see us next week, you know.
But we just won't be here in the studio.
We'll be in another studio.
- Hey, and check out my brand as well.
Shameless plugs, right at the end.
(laughing)
- All right, we'll catch
you guys next week!
- [All] Bye!
(chill music)